Nice!
Fuck!
What the hell?
Ah, ok jetzt backt die Soundcard nicht mehr rum.
Nice!
Sehr entspannend, so sieht es aus.
Huge relaxing ASMR Aquarium Stream.
Jetzt hat mir letztens einer auf der Arbeit erzählt, der geht demnächst in Rente.
Hat er gemeint so, ja er will sich ein Haus kaufen in Andalusien, also da in Spanien irgendwo.
Und wisst ihr was das einzige ist woran ich denken konnte?
Als er gesagt hat, er will sich ein Haus in Andalusien kaufen.
Ratet mal, in welches Emote war das einzige woran ich denken konnte?
8 Monate Patrick, dankeschön, nice.
Richtig, keck weh, was sonst?
Weil dieser Typ, das Original Interviews, wie heißt das?
Irgendwie Elrisitas, ach kein Elrisitas.
Ich weiß nicht wie man das ausspricht.
Der ist ja irgendwie aus Andalusien und da geht es darum, dass der halt irgendwelche Pfannen im Meer versenkt hat.
Wer will sich ein Haus in Andalusien?
Ich nicht, irgend einer auf der Arbeit hat mir das erzählt.
Wenn er in Rente geht, kauft er sich ein Haus in Andalusien.
Und das einzige woran ich denken muss, was keck weh.
Hat mich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich interessiert.
Aber keck weh war das einzige woran ich denken konnte.
Dicht gefolgt von Ayaya.
Ist der Sound irgendwen anders auch kaputt oder bin ich das nur?
Also ich habe es jetzt gerade in der Vorschau.
In der Vorschau ist nichts kaputt.
Übrigens Leute, wir müssen noch mal wieder den Stream beobachten, weil wir wissen ja immer noch nicht, ob Unity Media es geschafft hat,
meine Stream-Probleme zu fixen.
Aktuell habe ich nichts gedroppt.
Allerdings muss man sagen, ich habe den Stream auch auf gigantische 1,9 MBit gestellt.
Also ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob das Bild überhaupt scharf ist.
Das Bild scharf, ich mache das mal kurz im Fullscreen.
Ja, sieht halbwegs scharf aus.
Gut, meine Standbilder gehen auch mit 2 MBit.
Alles top.
Ja, ich meine, es wird nicht so viel Bewegung geben heute videomäßig.
Also insofern, das kann durchaus sein, dass das funktioniert.
Sollte es ruckeln, liegt es nicht an mir und Unity Media, dann muss ich sie wieder auf Twitter flamen.
Nachdem mir ja der Techniker erzählt hat, das letzte Mal, wo ich mit denen telefoniert habe,
das garantiert an meinem WLAN, dass das DSL Modem bei ihnen irgendwie Fehler wirft.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, mit denen muss ich eigentlich gar nicht weiter telefonieren.
Das hat nicht wirklich sittlichen Mehrwert, die ganze Geschichte.
Exzellent.
Wir haben übrigens einen WLAN-Emote.
Habt ihr das schon gesehen?
Chat?
Wir haben Tri-Fi.
Wir haben ja WLAN-Geschichten.
Aber ich bin da nicht über WLAN drin.
Das ist ja gerade der Witz.
Ich bin da mit dem Desktop angeschlossen.
Ich bin mit dem Desktop und dem Kabel angeschlossen.
Also im Prinzip, das kann damit überhaupt nichts zu tun haben.
Und vor allem, am besten fand ich immer noch, wie der Techniker angefangen hat,
mit diesen 0815 Oma-Noob-Erklärung.
So nach dem Motto, das hat er jetzt ernsthaft erzählt.
Wenn ihr WLAN Kevin1 und Kevin2 heißt, dann weiß das Handy nicht, was es verwenden soll.
Nee, Schwachsinn.
Wenn es zweimal Kevin1 gibt, dann weiß es nicht, welches WLAN das Handy verwenden soll.
Das hat er ernsthaft erzählt.
Und dann habe ich mit Dakotamo gedacht, Alter, das hat doch keinen Sinn.
Five-Headed.
Richtig huge brain.
Das ist hier Sixhead, mindestens.
Mindestens.
Mindestens Sixhead.
Den brauche ich auch noch.
Moment, warte mal, Leute.
Safe-Image.
Ich muss das hinzufügen.
Sixhead.
Ganz wichtig.
Get.
Sixhead.
Alter, ich kann nicht schreiben.
Upload.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
So muss das sein.
Das ist, wenn Five-Head nicht mehr reicht und das Hirn besonders groß ist, dann kann das gerade noch so mithalten.
Wie läuft es mit dem Gigabit-Anschluss?
Ich habe noch keinen Gigabit-Anschluss beantragt.
Die sollen erst mal ihren Crap hinkriegen, bevor ich meinen Vertrag um zwei Jahre verlängere.
Da Kupfermann.
Vier Monate.
Excellent.
Huge IQ-Chat.
Jetzt geht alles.
Sehr gut.
Also ich werde euch mal kurz erzählen, was wir heute machen.
Ich muss mal kurz mit Chat drüber gucken.
Ich habe wieder ein paar Sachen übersehen.
Erst mal schauen, ob ich alle Subs mitgekriegt habe.
Ja.
Du musst mal Three-Head im Discord, also im Auto.
Hab ich doch.
Ist doch drinne.
Wie heißt dieses Meme?
Was?
Du meinst den da?
El Resitas.
Wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Das ist Spanisch.
El Resitas.
Oder so.
Seht ihr das mit dem Sound?
Das da?
Aiaia Intensifies.
Ja.
Für die ganzen Weeps unter uns.
Aiaia Intensifies.
Was ist das da?
Hör mal auf.
Es ist gerade zu viel.
Es ist zu viel auf einmal.
Das halte ich gerade nicht aus.
Okay, also was waren wir heute?
Wir gucken uns natürlich erst mal das Aquarium noch kurz an.
Und während das Aquarium läuft.
Guck mal, das Aquarium kann sich sogar resizen.
Das ist doch mal.
Das ist den Sixhead wert, oder?
Guck mal, wie zentriert der Sixhead in der Mitte des Bildschirms ist.
Boah.
Ha?
Ungewollt.
Das ist hier quasi.
Da brauche ich gar keine Leiste mehr, um meine Terminals zu trennen.
Ich kann einfach den Kopf dazwischen machen.
Wunder der Technik.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Was hältst du von diesem Emote?
Das geht bei mir gerade nicht auf.
Hä?
Das haben wir doch.
Das haben wir doch schon.
Das haben wir doch schon längst drinnen.
Der schickt das falsche.
Kann das sein, dass FrankerFacesZ gerade übelst lahm ist, die Seite?
Das ist lustig, ja.
Fickmuffs.
So, habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
Stellst du dein Elgato Stream Decoding Programm zur Verfügung?
Was für ein Ding?
Elgato Stream Decoding Programm?
Was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was überhaupt.
Ach, du meinst mein Fake Stream Deck Ding.
Nein.
Noch nicht.
Also es gibt eine uralt Version gibt es auf GitHub.
Aber die aktuelle, also sprich die mit Sounds und die mit Text-to-Speech und sowas, die ist noch nirgendwo.
Und die ist auch nur, die ist auch gar nicht, die ist so kaputt eigentlich.
Ihr seht das immer bloß nicht.
Die Software ist total kaputt.
Ich habe die nie richtig fertig gemacht.
Und zwar, wenn man hier jetzt beispielsweise falsche Sachen hochlegt, stürzt das ab und sowas.
Also das ist voll für'n Arsch.
Das einzige Grund, warum das bei mir im Stream, guck mal, die Suche, die Suche ist auch kaputt.
Das einzige, warum das bei mir im Stream so gut funktioniert ist, weil ich weiß, was ich nicht drücken darf.
Easy.
Ja genau, das ist, der Eichler hat recht, das ist eine uralt Version, die kann aber noch gar nix.
Aber der Patrick kommt mit seiner 10 Gigabit Leitung um die Ecke.
Bei uns sind die Leute teilweise froh, wenn sie eine 50 MBit Leitung kriegen.
Oder eine 16 MBit Leitung.
Und bis jetzt noch keine Dropped Frames.
Aber wir wollen's mal nicht beschwören.
Also es kann sein, dass es gleich losgeht.
Je nachdem, was mit Unity Media abgeht.
Drück mal was Falsches, ne.
Drück nix Falsches.
Geht zwar kaputt.
Kannst du in einem Stream mal von deinen Berufsschul- und Ausbildungsstories erzählen?
Oder musst du mich ein bisschen genauer fragen?
Also da gibt's viel und wenig.
Also erstens fällt mir jetzt spontan wenig ein.
Und zweitens, insgesamt war das 3 Jahre oder?
Ne, ne, wie lang? 2,5 Jahre?
Äh, da gab's schon jede Menge Sachen.
Ich kann euch nur sagen, die Berufsschule, auf der ich gewesen bin.
Äh, Siemens, Schule, Dings, Fisi.
Ist die letzte Kack Berufsschule überhaupt.
Die hat ihre 2,1 Sterne vollkommen zurecht.
Also, ich mein, Berufsschulen haben alle schlechte Bewertungen, ne.
Aber die ist wirklich grausam schlecht.
Das ist die mit dem Knast, genau.
Ähm, man sieht leider nix.
Leider gibt's von dieser Berufsschule keine Bilder von innen.
Die wissen auch schon warum.
Weil die von innen wirklich aussieht wie ein Knast.
Hier, sowas hier.
Gut, das hat jetzt einer ein bisschen Bild manipuliert, aber so.
Ja, also es gibt lustigerweise keine.
Allein schon, oh Gott, der Eingang, wenn man den hier schon sieht.
Ähm, lull.
Es gibt keine.
Doch, das ist ein Raum von innen.
Es gibt leider keine richtigen Bilder von innen, aber das ist Absicht.
Ja, krasser PC Raum, oder?
Ach ne, das ist die andere.
Aber die ist wirklich hässlich.
Also ich kann keinem empfehlen, der da hingeht.
Ich weiß, dass alle unsere Azubis aus Frankfurt, die müssen da hingehen.
Weil das wahrscheinlich die einzige Schule in der Ecke ist.
Halt Berufsschule für Fisis.
Aber das sagt, das ist wirklich mega rollig.
Ansonsten kann ich da nicht viel erzählen.
Außer, dass die Ausbildung an sich halt total einfach gewesen ist.
Also, wer wirklich in der Physi-Ausbildung es schafft, Fünfer und Sechs dazu schreiben,
das ist eigentlich gar nicht möglich.
Ist es denn so schwer, einmal ein Git Push zu machen?
Nö, ist nicht schwer.
Das ist...
So, also ich zeige euch mal, was wir heute machen.
Ich glaube, wir haben schon mal daran rumgespielt, vor zwei Jahren oder so.
Die Sache ist plus die.
Musik ist ein bisschen laut.
Wir haben vor ein paar Jahren schon mal dran rumgespielt.
Das hat ja auch die ganze Zeit funktioniert.
War er schon im Keller und hat den Pi an die Heizung angeschlossen?
Ja, war ich.
War ich.
Ich war schon im Keller.
So, und zwar hier.
Pi add der da.
Der heißt auch schon so toll, Keller-Pi.
Damit ich Bescheid weiß, was da Sache ist.
Das haben wir vor ein paar Jahren ja schon gemacht.
Vor 1-2 Jahren im Stream ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Und prinzipiell funktionierte das Ganze auch.
Das einzige, also eines der Probleme, die ich hatte aktuell ist,
dass aus irgendwelchen Gründen, ich weiß nicht genau,
warum hat das Ding im Keller öfters mal seine WLAN-Verbindung verloren
und war da nicht mal connected.
So, und ich habe gedacht, ich bin besonders schlau
und habe es dann so eingestellt, dass ich das Ding einfach rebooted.
Das checkt einfach, ob es geht, wenn ich rebooted.
Aber das war keine schöne Lösung.
Ich bin dann irgendwann darauf gekommen,
dass die Stromversorgung im Keller dort,
wo ich den Raspberry Pi angeschlossen habe,
aus Gründen, die ich mir nicht genauer verstehe,
irgendwie manchmal nicht funktioniert.
Das ist eine ganz normale Steckdose unten im Keller
und da ist halt so eine Remote-schaltbare Steckdose drinne
mit zwei USB-Steckern und einem normalen Stecker.
Und irgendwie kackt das Ding manchmal ab.
Und für Leute, die schon ein paar Raspberry Pis im Einsatz hatten,
die werden wissen, dass Raspberry Pis das nicht gut verkraften,
wenn der Strom öfters mal weg ist.
Die kacken auch mal ganz gerne ab, sodass die SD-Karte nicht mehr bootbar ist.
Das ist ein Raspberry Pi Zero.
Den könnte ich wahrscheinlich von irgendwie,
ich weiß gar nicht, kann das Zero SSD booten?
Eventuell, aber mal davon abgesehen,
ich will da keine SSD reinstöpseln.
Ich habe mir jetzt eine neue MicroSD-Karte gekauft,
nämlich eine Samsung Pro Endurance.
Also der ist besonders ausgiebig und ausdauernd.
So ein Teil hier.
Und ich hoffe mal, damit gibt es dann weniger Probleme.
Das nächste ist, warum ich das auch nochmal neu machen muss,
dass ich irgendeine olle Version von diesem Ding,
was mit der Heizung kommuniziert habe,
von dem da, was ab und zu beim Auslesen Fehler hat.
Ups, ich zeige euch jetzt mal, wie das ganze prinzipiell funktioniert.
Es gibt findige Leute, die haben sich hingesetzt
und haben sich angeschaut, wie man an die Daten kommt von der Heizung.
So, und ich zeige euch mal, wie das ganze,
ne, ne, die MicroSD-Karte ist nicht komplett RIP.
Die MicroSD-Karte, die Rasparies machen nur ganz gerne mal
die MicroSD-Karte insofern kaputt, dass sie nicht mehr booten.
Wenn ihr die Dinge neu flasht, geht es meistens wieder.
Wahrscheinlich würde es auch reichen, wenn man
irgendwie Krabb neu installiert oder so.
Ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert, aber Rasparies sind bekannt dafür,
dass sie das machen.
Deswegen habe ich da unten im Keller jetzt auch so eine Mini-USB dran,
die ich euch schon ein paar Mal gezeigt habe hier.
AliExpress, ähm,
das Ding USB zu nennen, ist ja der Witz.
Ich habe da gerade Penis-Spinning gelesen.
Was ist denn auf AliExpress wieder los, Alter?
Pen-Spinning, ähm,
Raspberry Pi USB.
Sowas hier, bloß mit einer.
Äh, also kostet 2,50 Euro bei AliExpress.
Coronavirus.
Übrigens, mein Liebling, habe ich euch das schon erzählt,
mein Lieblings-Shop auf AliExpress
für, äh, Microcontroller-Zeug
ist, ähm, nicht,
ist geschlossen.
Oh, oh, er ist anscheinend wieder off.
Er ist geschlossen gewesen wegen Coronavirus.
Wusste ich gar nicht, ob ich das Paket aufmachen darf.
Also, und zumindest eines dieser Boards,
wo ich jetzt nichts ums Verrecken nicht finde, irgendwie,
ähm, ich habe mir da mal so ein 10er-Pack gekauft.
Vielleicht soll ich, vielleicht soll ich nach UPS suchen.
Es ist im Prinzip so ein Ding hier,
bloß mit einer Batterie nur drinne.
Reicht aber auch.
Da kommt so, da kommt eine Batterie rein,
die ist, das ist die gleiche Batterie,
aus denen auch normale Akkus ausprobiert werden.
Beziehungsweise auch so Batterien,
wie in E-Zigaretten reinkommen.
Das hat, glaube ich, das Ding hat,
ich glaube, 2500 mAh.
Das heißt, da läuft so ein Raspberry Zero
auch immer ein paar Stunden dran.
Der läuft nicht wirklich lange,
aber läuft ein paar Stunden dran.
Und Strom ist ja auch meistens nicht lange weg.
Das heißt, ich erhoffe mir jetzt,
dass das Ding weniger, weniger Probleme macht,
äh, einmal durch die Stromversorgung
und einmal durch die bessere,
äh, MicroSD-Karte.
So.
Das, das hoffe ich, so.
Und, äh, ich habe hier das Ding am Start,
das steht gerade unten im Keller.
Angeschlossen habe ich es schon.
Also hier sprich unter, äh,
DEV USB, ja Quatsch,
äh, links, USB 0.
Das ist der Adapter.
Das ist ein, ich zeige euch mal,
wie das an der Heizung aussieht.
Opto Link-Kabel.
Das ist so nett.
Das ist so ein Ding,
man weiß gar nicht.
Genau, hier sieht man es schön.
Vorne an der Heizung ist so ein Ding.
Also so ein V,
weil sie sich gedacht haben, passt gut zum Hersteller.
Und da vorne rein
steckt man dann einen Adapter.
Und der Adapter, der,
also der hat keinen mechanischen Kontakt hier irgendwie,
das ist einfach nur, dass er nicht runterfällt.
Äh, das geht über Infrarot.
Das ist dann so ein Kabel hier.
Das hat dann vorne zwei
Infrarot-LEDs.
Und, äh, hier, hier sieht man es auch ganz gut.
Genau, so ein Kabel kriegt man da.
Ja, genau so sieht das aus.
Das steckt man hier an Raspberry dran.
Und hier stöpselt man das an die Heizung.
Und, äh, das
kommuniziert dann über Infrarot-LEDs
über irgend so ein special, eigenes Protokoll
von Wiesmann.
Und nachdem das natürlich absolut
proprietär
Closed Source Herstellerzeug ist,
ist das auch nicht gedacht dafür,
dass man da Sachen damit ausliest.
Nichtsdestotrotz geht das Ganze,
weil, äh,
findige Leute auf GitHub,
ähm,
haben dieses Ding hier programmiert.
Also die haben das Protokoll quasi nachgebaut
von dem, von dem Hersteller.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt
einen Raspberry Pi hat, wo man hier V-Control drauf
kompiliert, muss man gleich machen,
dann kann man das über diese Optolink-Schnittstelle
auslesen. Das probieren wir jetzt
gleich mal aus. Also ich weiß, dass es funktioniert,
ich hab's ja vorher auch schon gemacht.
Also das ist jetzt gar nicht so die Frage, ob es überhaupt geht.
Und dann schauen wir mal,
ob wir das irgendwie
besser integriert kriegen.
Also wir gucken erstmal, was für Kommandos wir brauchen,
was das Ding so alles auslesen kann.
Weil außer Temperatur und
Fehlercode, ich hab eigentlich nie großartig
was ausgelesen, ich weiß gar nicht, was das alles kann.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob wir nicht
vielleicht irgendwie
ein.NET-Programm oder irgendwas
basteln, womit ich das Ganze
schöner auslesen kann
und in meine Heimautomatisierung pumpen kann.
Vielleicht machen wir das auch heute und teilweise morgen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie weit wir kommen bei der ganzen Geschichte.
So, als erstes müssen wir das
mal klonen.
Ich mach mal ein Update.
Ich mach mal ein Update, kann ja nichts schaden.
Erst einmal ein Update.
Update. Mal gucken,
wie viel. Das Ding ist
ewig alt.
Matt schreibt,
seine Schwester ist in China und meint, die Straßen
sind alle quasi komplett leer.
Restaurants und so haben auch alle geschlossen.
Dann
per MQTT in Home Assistant
rein. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich.
Muss ich mir erst mal gucken. Ich hab mir auch schon überlegt,
ob wir nicht den eigenen Prometheus-Exporter basteln.
Und
das dann
quasi irgendwie in Grafana haut
oder irgendwas bescheuert das.
Ich will erst mal gucken, dass das Programm funktioniert.
Was hab ich denn da eigentlich nur für ein Betriebssystem
drauf?
Ne, was ist das?
Demian-Release?
Demian-Version.
9.11. Was ist
Demian? Ist das noch das alte?
Ist das noch Stretch?
Oder ist das schon, was hab ich denn hier schon drauf?
Das ist noch Stretch.
Okay.
Ich trau mich nicht zu upgraden.
Ich trau mich grad nicht
zu upgraden, weil das Problem ist,
wenn
ich das jetzt upgrade
und aus irgendwelchen Gründen das WLAN nicht mal
funktioniert oder der Raspberry Pi nicht
mal ordentlich bootet unten im Keller.
Ich hab keine Lust
in Keller zu gehen und das Ding
quasi ein- und auszustöpseln und dann
hochzubringen, zu fixen, wieder runterzubringen,
anzuschließen. Ich lass einfach mal die Finger weg.
Ich upgrade jetzt einfach mal nix.
Ich lass das jetzt einfach mal
so wie es ist.
Es ist zwar 9.11, aber ich mein drauf
geschissenes funktioniert hier erst mal.
So. Wir
clonen uns erst mal das Repo.
Und dann gucken wir mal was bei der Heizung so alles aus.
No risk, no fun.
Wir können das mit dem upgraden machen,
wenn es funktioniert.
Also sprich, wenn das mit dem Auslesen funktioniert
alles, dann können wir vielleicht nochmal upgraden.
Schreibt mir das mal auf, dass wir
nachher nochmal ordentlich
upgraden.
Just do it.
Ja gut, wenn ich das jetzt mache und es geht
nicht, dann mach ich den Stream wieder aus.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das so in unsrem
Allerinteresse ist, dass ich das jetzt
update.
Also Leute, wir machen eine Abstimmung.
Wir stimmen das jetzt ab.
Also update.
Also wie gesagt, wenn das
Update nicht geht,
wenn das Update nicht geht
und ich da im Keller
erst rumrennen muss,
dann mach ich den Stream aus.
Dann hab ich keinen Bock drauf zu streamen,
hoch und runter in den Keller zu rennen,
anzuschließen und sonst was.
Konnte sich das nicht mal
live updaten?
Doch, ah jetzt. Ah, yes.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie ein Update gemacht.
Von Stretch auf Buster.
Ich hab keinen Bock jetzt in den Keller zu laufen.
Das ist ja grad der Witz, warum ich das nicht machen will.
Zeig uns das Kuchendiagramm.
Hat das so was?
Hat das einen Tortendiagramm?
Ja, hat's. Echt, wo?
Sort by?
Wir live streamen im Keller.
Muss den Browser kurs haben.
Ah, yes.
Excellent, excellent.
Hier ist exquisite Tortendiagramm.
Huge.
Huge Tortendiagramm.
Okay, also ich seh's schon,
ich soll updaten.
Das ist halt auch nicht
sonderlich spektakulär. Aber gut,
wenn ihr das haben wollt, dann mach ich das.
Also dann machen wir erstmal
noch ein Update und machen erstmal alle Pakete.
Und wenn alle Pakete drauf sind,
dann rebooten wir und weil wir gerebooted haben
und das Ding dann startet und
den Wlan immer noch drin ist,
dann machen wir ein Update von
Stretch auf Buster.
Muss ich mal gucken, wie man das überhaupt macht.
Unter Ubuntu wüsste ich's, aber wie machst du unter Debian?
Vor allem Raspberry, aber hab ich keinen Schimmer, wie das funktioniert.
How to upgrade
Stretch
to Buster.
Raspberry Pi. So.
Gut. Der Bat
Robot erklärt uns, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Ja, das hatte ich eh vor zu machen.
Ubuntu.
So, also
Upgrade.
Demokratie hat
wieder gewonnen. Ja, wenn das schon woanders nicht klappt,
dann muss es wenigstens hier funktionieren.
Aber das hier ist ja, das erhebt ja auch nicht
den Anspruch hier irgendwie demokratisch zu sein.
Wenn ich keinen Bock hab, dann gib's einfach nicht.
Und das ist dann
kann nichts dagegen
machen.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ich
in Hanau wohne?
Ich hab's ja auf Twitter geschrieben.
Aber, ähm, diese
Amoklauf-Geschichte oder
diese Attentat-Geschichte war
komplett, wie weit ist Hanau?
Also da wo ich wohne ist es nicht, also ich kann direkt
Flugsteigen kommen in Frankfurt raus.
Diese Attentat-Geschichte da,
die ist ja an einer anderen
Ende, naja nicht ganz am anderen Ende, die ist ein Stückchen
weg von mir.
Das ist ja quasi in der Innenstadt, wo das
gewesen ist.
Oh, huge.
Ich mein, das Ding ist halt, ne, die Dinger
sind nicht schnell. Das können wir dem Update-Balken
beim Updaten zugucken. Aber Chat?
Der Chat wollte das so.
Brüchtig dafür, viel in Shisha-Bars zu sein.
Ja, genau.
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich war glaube ich noch nicht einmal in einer Shisha-Bar.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich da soll.
Na gut, Shisha rauchen.
Aber, warum
sollte ich Shisha rauchen?
Wonka Smoke.
Der Grund, warum ich da nicht
reingehe, ist ehrlich gesagt aber nicht so sehr,
ähm,
nicht so sehr die
Wasserpfeife,
und auch nicht weil irgendwie
Lunge und Krebs und sonst was,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob das großartig schädlich ist,
sondern das Publikum, was man da teilweise
drum herum sieht, ist nicht so das,
womit ich mich gerne zusammensetzen will
und einen rauchen.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich bei allen
Shisha-Bars ähnlich.
Ja, nun bitte,
könnt ihr so viel abstimmen, wie ihr wollt.
Wenn das Update geht und ich mehrfach in den Keller rennen muss,
dann ist das Stream vorbei.
Tinder-Dates in der Shisha-Bar.
Der Hack-Store kennt sich aus.
Max kommt nur, wenn Haft die auch ansteigen.
Ja, ich hab euch ja erzählt, dass es gut sein kann,
dass ich letztens mit Haftbefehl mexikanisch essen war
und ich das als
Deutsch-Rap-Banause gar nicht mitgekriegt habe.
Boah, das Update ist huge schnell.
Ja, ich hab's doch im Stream erzählt,
wir sind in diese mexikanischen
Laden reingegangen
in Hanau, äh, nicht in Hanau, in Frankfurt,
der Kaiserstraße
und als wir reinkommen sind, haben die Mädels
da irgendwie wild Selfies gemacht mit einem.
So, und der ist dann raus
und ich hab die eine gefragt, ich dachte mir,
was war das denn? Und die haben sich vorher irgendwas von Haft
die Abi sonst was erzählt
und da meinte die halt zu mir, die hat nicht den Namen gesagt,
sondern nur ein Deutsch-Rapper.
Also wer weiß, vielleicht war das ja Haftbefehl.
Vielleicht ein Lebensziel
erreicht, da war ich quasi im gleichen Mexikaner
wie Haftbefehl.
Easy.
Deutsch-Rap ist schlimmer
als Schlager.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich schlechter
finden soll. Also wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise die Auswahl habe
zwischen Haftbefehl oder
wie heißt der andere, Wendler
oder so,
da würde ich wahrscheinlich sogar eher Haftbefehl
hören. Egal.
Oder wie geht
dieses komische...
Genau.
So ein
Stoss ey.
Das ist so dumm, Alter.
Das ist so dämlich.
Nimm das egal
ins V-Bot auf. Soll ich?
Soll ich das aufnehmen?
Okay.
Wartet mal.
Da muss ich aber erst ein GIF
draus machen.
Okay, jetzt wird's aber echt
kompliziert, da ein GIF draus.
Oder reicht der Sound?
Reicht der Sound oder muss es ein GIF sein?
Warum kann ich nicht mal mein Heimatverzeichnis wechseln?
What the fuck?
Muss ein GIF sein,
Leute? Muss es ein GIF sein?
Ich weiß...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum
ich hier nicht in mein
Heimatverzeichnis rein kann.
Okay, ich hab's falsch benannt, aber
egal.
Dann machen wir jetzt YouTube Download.
So, also ich zeig euch mal, wie man
jetzt Big Brain GIFs erzeugt.
Minus F.
Kann man sich anzeigen lassen, was es für
Format gibt.
Okay, X.
Mein Memepod
kann, glaube ich,
kein MP4.
Nee, ich glaub,
das kann kein MP4. Gute Frage,
ob das MP4 kann.
Ich will es nicht ausprobieren, weil
es besteht die Chance, dass ich es dann komplett kaputt mache.
Ähm...
Ich muss es wohl erstmal updaten, denke ich.
Wahrscheinlich ist die Version
einfach zu alt.
Nee, Webben
kann's garantiert nicht. Webben.
Webben.
So, jetzt geht's
wahrscheinlich.
So, jetzt laden wir das mal runter.
Und zwar als
vielleicht nicht ganz so hohe
Auflösung.
Irgendwas Kleines, so
640x360 oder so, ist glaube ich
ganz gut. Plus den Sound
laden wir runter.
139.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube, das kann das
gar nicht, Leute. Ich glaube, das kann
das gar nicht.
Das kann keine GIFs
mit Sounds.
Das kann keine GIFs mit Sounds.
Das hier ist nämlich
ein GIF mit
Text-to-Speech. Ich glaube, das Ding
kann gar keine GIFs
mit Sounds.
Wobei
Ich habe keine Ahnung
mehr, wie das funktioniert,
hat ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, wir testen
erst mal nur den Sound, ob das funktioniert.
Wir laden es
erst mal runter.
Okay,
wir testen erst mal
nur den Sound, ob das
funktioniert.
Wir laden es
erst mal runter.
Mal gucken, wie würde sich das denn anhören?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie edit man hier überhaupt
was?
Wie edit man hier überhaupt was hier?
Oh, es ist kaputt,
Leute.
Es ist kaputt.
Egal.
Siehst du, deswegen lade ich den Scheiß nicht
hoch, weil es einfach total im Arsch ist.
Lul.
L-U-L-W.
Okay.
What the fuck. Okay.
Egal.
Oh, es ist
kaputt. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ich sag doch, jetzt
und ihr fragt ernsthaft, warum ich das nicht
gemacht habe.
Das ist wirklich ernsthaft.
E-G-A-L.
Das passt nicht.
Egal.
Okay, also wir haben das Video erst mal.
Okay,
da müssen wir jetzt ein Gift draus machen. Das machen wir mit
ffmpeg.
Input.
Ich benenne das mal um,
dass die Datei irgendwie besser heißt.
Das heißt jetzt einfach nur
egal.mp4.
ffmpeg. Also wir nehmen jetzt, ich probiere jetzt mal aus,
ob es funktioniert. Es kann sein, dass es voll abkackt.
Nach egal.gif.
Okay, jetzt haben wir den GIF,
den Sound.
Okay, das GIF funktioniert schon mal.
Das GIF ist schon mal da.
Jetzt müssen wir nur
noch da draus ein
egal.waffe machen.
Okay,
jetzt haben wir schon mal beide Sachen.
Jetzt haben wir schon mal beide Sachen.
Okay, GIF.
Oh, ich habe das
sogar schon eingebaut, dass man zu einem GIF
Sounds hochladen kann, Leute.
Huge.
Vielleicht klappt das doch.
Egal.
Es ist aber nicht synchron, Leute.
Es ist nicht synchron, aber es
funktioniert fast.
Fast, oder?
Bissle asynch.
Egal.
Aber komm, also für das, dass ich gedacht habe,
dass es gar nicht funktioniert, funktioniert es doch
eigentlich ganz gut. Ich muss mal
meine, ich glaube, ich muss die,
wir müssen das nochmal
löschen. Und jetzt muss ich mal
gucken, wie macht man mit FFmpeg
den Sound leiser?
FFmpeg
Lower Volume.
Wie geht das?
Reduce Volume.
Reduce
Kilume.
Oh, jetzt
wird es echt advanced,
Leute. Wie geht das? Audio Volume.
To increase, nee, ich will nicht
increase, ich will decrease.
Ah, hier, hier. Filter
minus A. Ich sage euch, Leute,
FFmpeg,
das beste Tool überhaupt, was es gibt.
Ups.
Bestes Tool ever.
Gucken, wie die Lautstärke jetzt ist.
Jetzt ist es
ein bisschen zu leise, ne?
Mein Dezibel ist ja auch eine scheiß Einhalt,
da weiß man nie, was am Ende rauskommt.
Okay, war schon besser, schon besser.
So, und jetzt muss ich nur noch gucken, wie ich am Anfang,
wie ich am Anfang
eine Pause einbauen kann.
Also keine Pause, einfach,
einfach, ähm,
quasi, was brauchen wir, zwei Sekunden?
Zwei Sekunden Silenz.
Kommt, hier.
Using Concat
Demaxer.
Ach, du Scheiße.
Oh, das ist mir jetzt zu hoch.
What?
Ah, Delay Filter.
Oh.
Still,
silen.wav.
Okay, wir machen erstmal leise,
und dann machen wir noch einen Delay Filter.
Was?
Use, äh,
äh.
What?
Ah, ich glaube, ich muss so machen,
kann das sein?
Ah, yes, excellent.
So, und da ist jetzt, da ist jetzt
tatsächlich eine Pause dabei?
Ist da jetzt eine Pause dabei?
Wir machen mal fünf davor.
Das funktioniert.
Funktioniert.
Ernsthaft, FFmpeg, Leute,
ich sag's euch, wenn ihr Audio, Video, sonst was Probleme habt,
ihr müsst FFmpeg verwenden.
Bessere, bessere Sachen gibt's nicht.
Ich glaube, das Delay ist
ein bisschen groß, ha?
Wir machen wirklich mal nur eine Sekunde
Delay.
Okay,
okay, ja, jetzt können wir
aufladen.
Also, GIF,
GIF,
Sound,
Egal-Waff,
Was ein SYNC,
was ein SYNC,
hä?
Egal.
Huge.
Wie, das passt, das passt,
als wär's so gemacht worden, ey.
Mega brave, ja.
Ja.
Aber mal mindestens so, oder?
Mindestens war so.
Bekommen wir auch den Link zum GIF?
Es gibt keinen Link zum GIF.
Ich hab das Ding lokal erstellt, das GIF.
Und das GIF hat übrigens übelst
reutenkreu die schlechte Quali, ey.
Ähm, warum ist das eigentlich?
Warum ist das so laut?
Das ist viel zu laut.
Kann das sein, dass das
Volume Reduce jetzt nicht funktioniert hat?
Probieren wir mal aus, ich mach mal 50 dB
leiser.
Okay, doch, doch, das hat funktioniert.
Ähm,
mach mal 15, ich lad ich das Ganze
noch mal auf, weil das ist ein bisschen,
ein bisschen laut, das Ganze, ne?
Man könnte ja auch sagen, es ist egal.
Immer noch ein bisschen lauter.
Na, wobei, ne,
das ist, das ist, das ist gut so.
Zack, zack.
Das MemeBot ist doch besser als ich gedacht hab.
Hochladen.
So ist perfekt, oder?
So ist das, so hau, so hau das rein.
Wir sind ein wenig, ein wenig vom ursprünglichen Plan abgekommen.
Wir wollten eigentlich
unser Raspberry Pi updaten.
Aber der ist ja
so lahm, deswegen kann man solche Sachen in der Zwischenzeit
machen.
Mach mal plus 100 dB, ne, ne.
Warum soll ich denn sowas machen?
Ähm, was muss man machen? Upgrade, da muss man
irgendwie Dist Upgrade machen, das ist ja debian.
Das egal Meme war
wichtiger, eindeutig war das wichtiger.
Huge. So, wir haben
alles geupdated.
Bevor ich jetzt das Update auf Buster mache,
und das ist nicht egal,
egal.
Ähm, muss ich mal Rebooten.
Und wenn der Reboot nicht funktioniert,
haben wir gelitten.
Dann geht's nicht weiter.
Also.
Ich ping das Ding unten schon mal, dass wir sehen, was Sache ist.
Also noch, noch ist er, oh fuck.
Noch, noch ist er da.
Reboot, bam.
Okay, er ist schon mal weg.
Aber 7,
7.10 ist er weg.
Das passt echt gut, ey.
Oh Leute, ich glaube, damit werde ich euch
jetzt noch öfters nerven in den nächsten Tagen.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut, dass das mit dem GIF
funktioniert.
Oh, er ist wieder da.
Reboot hat funktioniert, das ist doch schon mal schön.
Nicht egal.
Okay.
Egal.
So, und jetzt muss man abkühlen.
Was heißt sie?
Das eigentlich komplizierte,
was heißt komplizierte.
Das eigentliche kommt jetzt ja noch.
Stimmt, warum habe ich so einen hohen ping?
Ach so, WLAN, WLAN Geschiss halt.
WLAN im Keller.
Der Empfang ist auch nicht sonderlich gut.
So,
ja.
Was,
was, was, was macht denn
dpk-c? Ich führ das jetzt einfach mal aus.
Nichts, okay.
Abtmarke Showhold.
Zeigt auch nichts.
Okay, Prepare.
Ist das wirklich so kompliziert?
Unter Ubuntu sagt man einfach
Release, Upgrade und gut ist.
Pie, ich suche mal nach
einer anderen Anleitung.
Upgrade, Stretch
to Buster.
Von Stretch auf Buster
auf to Upgrade.
Pie me
live ab.
Pie my life.
Das haben wir alles gemacht.
Was denn das für einen Schwachsinn?
Das ist totaler
Blödsinn, das würde ich im Leben nicht
machen. Dabei.
Das installiert Beta Kernel für die
alte Betriebssystem. Warum sollte man sowas denn machen?
Das ist total hängen gebliebene
Anleitung schon wieder.
Okay, anscheinend muss man doch das
hier machen. Also ist die
Anleitung schon ganz okay.
Upgrade, Abt, Sources.
Also,
wir sollen, äh, jetzt
kommt Chat Quiz Frage.
Was macht dieses Kommando hier?
Ja, für
die Niedlungsexperten.
Also ich meine, ich weiß es, ich will es bloß von euch wissen.
Weil
Wer
ist hier, wer hat das
Sixhead im Chat und weiß es, was es macht?
Kosten, nein.
Es ersetzt Stretch mit Buster, ja das ist richtig.
Ähm, aber der
ersetzt Stretch mit Buster, ersetzt Stretch, richtig.
Okay,
der Chat ist, der Chat ist, äh,
Big Brain.
Ähm, das stimmt, das ersetzt Stretch
durch Buster.
Allerdings, die große Preisfrage ist doch,
wenn das Stretch durch Buster
in der Datei hier ersetzt, warum
ersetzt das in der Datei?
Also warum ersetzt es das nicht nur in der Ausgabe,
sondern ersetzt es in der Datei?
Das ist ja der Knackpunkt an dem Kommando.
Warum geht das?
Und das geht
mit Minus E, weil
es ist nicht sonderlich
intuitiv, aber Minus E
bedeutet, glaube ich, in place.
Ähm, also sprich
normalerweise, und das muss man, das muss
man wissen, äh, normalerweise,
wenn ich das so mache, ohne Minus
E,
dann ersetzt er das nur
im Output, das heißt, wenn ich hier
jetzt reingucke, wenn ich in die
Datei reingucke, seht ihr, hier steht immer noch
Stretch drinnen, das heißt, der ersetzt
nur im Output, das heißt, wenn ich
Minus E mache, dann
ersetzt das in der Datei.
Das heißt, wenn man einfach nur den Output
ändern will, ohne die Datei, dann lässt man einfach das Minus E weg
oder macht das Minus E jetzt gar nicht mal hin.
So, also das da,
was ist denn das? Raspberry Pi
List?
Nee, E ist nicht Insert,
E ist in place,
weil
in place, genau, weil
Linux bzw. Unix
Kommandozeilen Tools nicht
sonderlich, ähm,
Big Brain sind,
was ihre Kommandozeilen
Argumente Benamung angeht.
Und in dem Fall ist es auch nicht,
ähm,
sondern,
manchmal ist es
Minus Minus Version, manchmal ist es Version,
manchmal ist es Minus V, Minus Groß Version,
die wissen alle nicht so genau,
was sie wollen. Bei Git geht übrigens beides,
Git geht Minus Minus Version
und es geht Version.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch nicht ausprobiert, ob auch
Version geht oder
vielleicht sogar V oder
Version oder so. Nee, aber anscheinend
geht plus zwei Varianten.
WTF war
was, das da? Also ich finde,
das ist ziemlich egal, was das war.
Das hat's mir jetzt angetan, ey.
Für jedes
egal, ein Shot,
wenn du danach komplett unter dem Tisch
liegen willst. So, also was haben wir jetzt gemacht?
Wir haben das hier geupdatet. Verify,
it's caught them all by running the following.
Oha, jetzt
wird's aber advanced hier.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Ich mein, das kann man machen, aber wir haben hier grad schon nachgeguckt.
Oh.
Es steht immer noch drin,
Leute. Immer noch eine Ausgabe in stretch, aber
ich geh mal davon aus, das liegt daran, das steht
in irgendeinem Comment drin.
Hier, point.
Hä?
Kann es sein, dass ich das andere gar nicht ausgeführt hab,
hier, von dem,
gut hier.
Ja, hab ich
gar nicht ausgeführt. Okay, wunderbar,
haben wir alles gemacht. Speed up,
steps by remove the list.
What's the list change package?
Okay, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal.
Ich find's ja schon merkwürdig, dass der
noch abget verwendet. Ich verwende ja
immer apt für alles.
Aber das haben wir schon.
Also wir machen jetzt erstmal ein Update.
Richtig educational stream.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Mal gucken,
ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ich hab noch nie ein Update gemacht auf
Raspberry Pi von stretch auf Buster.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum
die das so kompliziert machen, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil Ubuntu machst so
do-release-upgraden, das ist da.
Aber so
ein Update
ist apt oder apt-get nicht das gleiche.
Ne. Debian hat
drei verschiedene Paketmanager,
standardmäßig an Bord.
Apt-get, aptitude und apt.
Und
das ist auch nach der, das älteste
ist, glaub ich, apt-get. Danach haben sie gesagt
apt-get zackt, wir machen das jetzt mit
aptitude. Und dann haben sie gesagt, ach ne,
apt-get und aptitude zackt, wir machen
jetzt apt.
Also richtige Boomer, genau.
Geht do-release?
Ne. Ne, unter Debian nicht.
Big brain. So.
Was ist das eigentlich für ein Paket?
Ne, ich deinstallier das jetzt nicht.
Einfach.
Ach so, okay.
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, warum der das
deinstalliert. Okay, das ist doch ne gute
Idee, das hier zu entfernen.
Weil sonst zeigt der mir bei ganz vielen Paketen
an, hier Achtung, Changelog-Eintrag.
Weg damit.
Ja.
So, Upgrade haben wir jetzt.
Ne.
Weg damit. So, Upgrade haben wir.
Blablabla.
Yes.
Ah, yes.
Exzellent. Exzellent.
Der Raspberry Pi Zero ist halt einfach
ein lahmes Stück Hardware.
So, apt-get,
apt-grade.
Ich mach einmal ohne Yes,
weil ich wissen will, was er alles, wieviel er
schon updaten, was er alles macht.
Ich find das
egal, schon etwas. Also ich find's nicht
okay Champ, ich find's ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
pain Champ, aber das hab ich hier leider als
Emote nicht drinne.
Alternative to include kernel
modules and removing packages if
required.
The fuck?
Woher soll ich das
wissen, ob das required ist?
Ich upgrade jetzt erstmal.
Dist
Upgrade. Dist Upgrade können wir
auch machen.
Wir machen jetzt
erstmal das hier.
Das hauen wir dann noch hinten drauf.
Kommt mit den ganzen Drenz
also Tribulon, das musste mit
23, musste dann auch mitkommen.
Oder ist denn das ganze Zeug etwa
egal.
Sollte aber mit
23 auch nicht so sein.
Wir müssen
wir brauchen die passende Upgrade
Musik.
Wir brauchen die passende Upgrade
Musik Leute.
Guck mal, keine
Frames droppt.
Musik
Ja, Quatsch. Nein, natürlich haben die es nicht
geregelt bekommen. Das hat sich von alleine geregelt.
Weil es wahrscheinlich gar keine Probleme gab
zwischen mir und
Vodafone, weil Vodafone entweder
Karkruten ausgewählt hat,
kein ordentliches Peering hatte, die
irgendwas auf den W
if you
Computer gets
Wins
Was?
SMB Conf
Warum hab ich da überhaupt ne SMB Conf
Auf
Warum habe ich eine smb konf auf diesem system habe ich gar nicht oder
Yes
Warum sollte ich den samba drauf haben auf mein raspberry pi im keller das ist komplett das schwachste
Du du du du du du du samba ist doch standard dabei in den samba server ist nicht standard dabei
Du musst installieren ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher ob ein samba client standardmäßig dabei ist ich glaube auch nicht
Ja patrick so so das mache ich auch immer war da wahrscheinlich die meisten so
So
Hol dir doch ein smartmeter
Ich habe ein eigen eigen konstruiertes smartmeter viel besser
Ich habe oben also ich habe noch so einen ganz alten während das update kann ich habe noch so einen ganz alten
zähler hier so ein ding
Und einen neuen also ich habe für den ersten stocken 9 und für gesamt ist so was und ich habe so was tatsächlich
Nicht so was hier aber was ähnliches gebaut wie das hier
Ich habe mir ein esp 286
geholt habe einmal einen line verfolgungssensor gemacht der quasi hier erkennt wenn wenn die weiße linie unterbrochen wird
und hier oben auf den dingern steht dann immer drauf wie viel
Verbrauch quasi eine umdrehung ist da kann ich das mittelungen und
ein photoresistor der quasi der checkt wenn der stromzähler oben das ist so ein ding hier
blinkt
Also spricht das ist das ist quasi ein smartmeter ohne dass ich ein offizielles smartmeter braucht das ist exzellent ich weiß tribulon
exzellent
Hast du mal ein retro pie ausprobieren aber so exzellent ist das gar nicht weil das ist in der aktuellen variante
Bisschen doof gemacht weil ich das nur mit dem kleberband dran gemacht haben und das fällt manchmal runter deswegen bin ich grad dabei dass ein bisschen schöner zu machen
was
Was ist lip haben irgendwelche auch defizierungsgeschichte?
Yes
im zweifelsfall alles alles alles
Wenn er jetzt halt ssh
Wenn er jetzt ssh während dem update neu startet das wäre echt dumm
Und habe ich leute habe ich das in dem team habe ich das in der teamarkt session gemacht
Oder war ich einfach so eingeloggt ich habe das glaube ich in der teamarkt session gemacht oder
Aber die sache ist die da muss ich eigentlich die marktleiste sehen
Das wäre ziemlich low brain hätte ich das nicht in der teamarkt session gemacht
Das wäre das das das wäre das gegenteil von exzellent
Das wäre noch nicht mal
Das wird dazu führen dass das upgrade wahrscheinlich abkackt
De de de de de de sache noch kirby
Ich
Huge wahnsinnig
Geschwindig geschwindes update auf dem raspberry
also der zero ist halt
sehr praktisch dadurch dass es halt ein kleines teil ist ohne wähler mit wählern und genug schnitt stellen um alles zu machen mit
Einen vollwertigen linius drauf aber schnell ist was anderes
Wem schon der normale raspberry pie zu langsam ist der kriegt anfälle bei dem zero
Ich meine du kriegst ja heute eigentlich fast nichts mehr unter seit er vier kerne
Hat er mittlerweile haben die dinger ja mittlerweile
Das zero hat halt ein kern und noch niedriger getaktet
und
Was zero ist quasi so einen ich sage so in den achtel so schnell oder so wie in den raspberry pie vier
Oder wie ein raspberry pie drei zwischen vier und drei ist ja nicht so der wahnsinnsunterschied
Ripp gleich stream aus der stream geht ja nicht vom ich streame ja nicht von meinem raspberries pie zero
Das wäre nicht so clever
Gibt es jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind und uns die updates angucken wirst du na
Gibt es noch irgendwelche anderen memes die wir unbedingt brauchen hier mehmtool
Irgendwas neues nicht nicht die ganzen alten dinger irgendwas neues sowas hier wieder wendler
Alten dinger irgendwas neues sowas hier wieder wendler
Gibt es ja irgendwelche neuen trendigen
Twitch insider memes oder youtube was ich was ich gar so richtig harte summa memes
Weiß nicht wenn sie mir gefallen schon
Und
Paper an du meinst diesen clown der rennt oder ist paper an wieder was anderes achso das ist das
Das ist jetzt nicht so das war ich brauche wir haben schon einmal für den zahn am start
John Cena mal ne ne das das das das ist mir zu summa
Der gerät stimmt das gibt's was macht der typ eigentlich
Das ist er das sieht plus anders aus als stefan drab jetzt
Okay gibt es anscheinend immer noch der gerät
Muss groß mehm also hier bruder muss groß in die hohes
Ne das ist das ist alles zu zu zu deutsche summa memes die gefallen mir nicht
Ich bin da ich bin zu anspruchsvoll wahrscheinlich
Was was was bei dem board angeht was da reinkommt da kommt nur exzellent exquisite memes rein
Oder hohes stonks da sind wir fertig nein sind wir nicht kann man nichts machen leute
Ich muss gerade mal ein bisschen was weniger entspannendes anmachen hatten wir nicht was was empfiehlt mir youtube denn für musik gibt es da irgendwas
Best of red das hatten wir schon letztens an wobei da habe ich auch keine schmerzen noch mal zu machen beste
Der gerät tatsächlich die gibt's noch der gerät guck mal der gerät in der gerät in spanisch in französisch in englisch in türkisch
Und arabisch türkisch arabisch wahrscheinlich
Der typ der sieht auf jedem foto anders aus aber es ist das gleiche das nicht syrien ich
Hab keine ahnung das könnte das könnte ich würde eher sagen grüne flagge ist arabisch guck mal so verbreitet ist der gerät
Der hat aber viele geräte das update du bringst immer noch der gerät der gerät so sieht der gerät also aus guck mal der gerät hat sogar ein touch screen
Der hat echt den meme namen benutzt der wäre blöd wenn nicht der will den gerät verkaufen der gerät hat zumindest ein touch screen
Ich würde dir mal interessieren was da für ein controller drin ist er ist gesund sätigend und an fast jede ecke erhältlich so siehts aus
Einmal die woche gibt es bei mir auch döner teller abends oder alternativ wenn kein döner teller dann pide sucuk auch auch nicht schlecht
Aber nicht so oft also ich kann nicht jeden tag döner essen aber so einmal die woche muss das sein
Der döner robot eine überzeugende investition das schlimme daran ist ja oder was das gut daran ist ja mich überzeugt die werbung und das gerät
Um ein vielfaches mehr als die komische telekom werbung die wir uns das letzte mal angegessen haben
Die telekom werbung das letzte mal war so richtig grinsch diese diese born to be magenta telekom dna gelaber dann dann lieber der gerät
Der weiß anscheinend was er macht die magenta dns genau so fehl der fanshop guck mal der gerät hat einen eigenen fanshop
Der gerät der gerät für medels der gerät für typen der gerät trinkflasche der gerät cap alles alles der gerät gibt
Der muss halt gucken was die Kohle stimmt messetermin man kann sich sogar der ist voll dabei der ist voll im geschäft der gerät hier
Gucken wir uns das ganze noch mal auf arabisch an da verstehen wir wahrscheinlich alles ah yes excellent alles klar
Achso das ist ja das ist ja auch noch rechts nach links das ist ja auch noch rechts nach links ne das ist da das mit da explodiert mein kopf wenn ich sowas bedienen muss
Das kriege ich nicht gebacken
Aber vor allem dass der quasi wie apple einen angefressenen dünnerspieß hat apple hat einen angebissenes logo und er hat einen angebissenen dünnerspieß das ist eigentlich ist das richtig gut das ding was der hier gemacht hat ich finde das nice
So was macht unsere upgrades immer noch am upgraden okay
Der gerät für sie für ihn für alle
Ja der typ der ist richtig ja ich next next level five
Degerät schwitzt nicht und ist immer vor dem vor dem chef in der arbeit oder irgendwie so ich krieg den überhaupt nicht mal richtig zusammen
Ist vor dem chef im im geschäft
Vor dem chef im geschäft genau
Genau und schneidet der dünnerfleisch schweißfrei stimmt ja
Ja ich erinnere mich wieder das ist ja auch schon uralt kann man mal fertig updaten bitte in der zwischenzeit hier schon eine neue installation gemacht bis der durch ist
Eigentlich hatte ich vor wir probieren das auf dem respekt schnell aus und danach programmieren wir was was das was das benutzt aber wenn ich mir das hier so angucke wie lange das so dauert
Ich glaube es ist gleich fertig leute gleich fertig
Oder auch nicht ja gibt es sonst noch irgendwelche wichtigen sachen die wir besprechen müssen der gerät aus außer der gerät
Gibt es irgendwas neues gibt es denn heute für news zeigt mal her was gibt es denn heute für fiverr emotes da gibt es nicht viel zu diskutieren gibt es ja heute auch ne oder
Das ist nicht euer ernst geht mal weg mit dem scheiß
Das konnte man doch das konnte man doch skippen oder da gab es doch so ein trick wie man das wie man das überspringen konnte
Immer die schuld für alles auf den chat schieben man muss die schuld nicht auf den chat schieben der chat hat einfach schuld das hat mit schieben nichts zu tun
Der chat ist an allem schuld man konnte doch irgendwie mit trick 17 trotzdem noch offline konto machen was die bisherige verfügung zwischen einem lokalen offline und einem micro
Was heißt das kann man das kann man bestimmt noch trick 17 machen
Die internetverbindung beim set abzukappen hilft auch hier
Ah yes excellent warum warum machen die es einem so schwer
Warum machen war okay pro ist ausgenommen da kann ich weiterhin offen aber warum machen die es einem mit ihrem kack so schwer
Warum machen ich verstehe das nicht warum müssen die es einem so schwer machen und vor allem warum wenn ich es gibt überhaupt keinen sinnvollen
Grund dafür warum man sich mit einem Microsoft account einloggen kann offline bei sich auf dem desktop
Die ganzen Sachen in der in den in den einstellungen im set ab die die die ganzen tracking geschichten musste auch alle einzeln anklicken und dann kannst du nicht etwa auswählen am ende
Zwischen kein tracking sondern nur noch zwischen wenig tracking und und und viel tracking kein tracking gibt es gar nicht
Oh man das ist so fehl warum warum gehen die einem so auf den sack
Mit daten können die auch ohne Microsoft account gut genug sammeln wenn ich nämlich irgendeinen Dienst verwenden will sei es jetzt irgendwie xbox hotmail outlook office
Irgendwas da muss ich mich doch einloggen oder haben die schiss dass die leute keine Microsoft dienste verwenden außer Windows
Das ist natürlich auch durchaus möglich ja was gibt es sonst noch für neue News gibt es irgendwas interessantes
Oh davon sind wir auf der Arbeit auch betraut sie machen alle Panik jetzt weil man LWS verwenden muss dabei warum
Desinformation die manchmal haben die auch den Schuss da mal gehört
Was kommt als nächstes wenn ich was falsches denke steht die Polizei vor der Tür oder wie
Gute Musik ja nice beste
Ich wollte euch die Hardcore Wikinger Heavy Metal Geschichten ersparen habe ich mir gedacht machen wir mal wieder Retro Chili Peppers Best Of an
Oh das Update ist so geschwind
Die sollen mal gute Klimapolitik das geht nicht also man kann man kann nicht erwarten dass da irgendjemand was in deinem Interesse und unserem Interesse macht das kann nicht sein
Ich finde es ja genauso bescheuert vor allem in Frankfurt waren sie so am diskutieren danach dem motto hier CO2 und Umweltbelastung in der Stadt
Und so was wir müssen die Leute verbieten mit dem Auto in die Stadt zu fahren und generell den Leuten verbieten mit dem Auto zu fahren
Da habe ich mir so an der Stelle gedacht was machen Leute die mit dem Auto fahren müssen weil sie irgendwo irgendwo Scheiß Anbindung haben
Wäre nicht die überzeugendere Taktik dass man den Nahverkehr so gut ausbaut dass man sich erstens drauf verlassen kann
Was ja heute teilweise überhaupt nicht so ist dass man sich darauf verlassen kann dass es billiger ist und dass es bequem ist
Und wenn die drei Sachen erfüllt sind dann werden ganz viele Leute nicht mal mit dem Auto in die Stadt fahren
Und dann wenn das der Fall ist und die Leute immer noch drauf scheißen dann kann man sich vielleicht überlegen ob man das den Leuten verbieten sollte mit dem Auto in die Stadt zu fahren
Aber man kann doch nicht den zweiten Schritt vor dem ersten Schritt machen
Der erste Schritt ist eindeutig der Nahverkehr muss besser werden wenn der Nahverkehr besser ist
Wenn du ankommst wenn es bequem ist und wenn es günstig ist das sind Kombinationen dann würden die meisten gar nicht mit dem Auto fahren
Aber das ist wie gesagt zweiter Schritt vor dem ersten machen deswegen habe ich es mir abgeschminkt dass irgendjemand dort was in meinem Interesse macht
Hat den Vorteil man wird auch nicht mehr enttäuscht weil sonst müsste man sich die ganze tache aufregen
Jetzt habe ich ein bisschen leise gemacht
Aber Chat ich kann es noch mal sagen ihr wolltet das Update der Chat ist in dem Fall wie ich gesagt habe man muss die Chat die Schuld gar nicht auf den Chat schieben
So jetzt auch irgendwelche interessanten News
Auf die Idee hätte man vorher natürlich nicht kommen können bevor man das einführt
Versteckte Neuerungen von iOS 13 Nutzen
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die alten Zeitschriften die es früher gab so nach dem Motto Windows Tricks die nicht einmal Microsoft kennt
Passwort Manager im Test mal gucken was die getestet haben
Oh Update ist fertig Leute easy
So wie geht es weiter wir müssen jetzt noch ein Dist Upgrade machen
Wahrscheinlich brauchen wir das nicht aber mal gucken
Plus Artikel hast du ein Abo ich habe ein Abo ja aber ich bin ja nicht einge
Warum Upgrade das noch so viel nachdem ich das vorher schon gemacht habe
Dann ist die Update Anleitung Kacke
Dann Sack die Update Anleitung nehmen wir mal die hier
Machen wir noch mal ein ordentliches Update
Hallo ich will das da rein kopieren
Ok Leute Update ist noch nicht fertig wir müssen noch mal 5 Minuten Updaten
Das dauert 3 Stunden
Ich sag dazu nur
Warum nicht einfach Arch weil es nicht Arch ist
Das dauert 3 Stunden warum sollte das so viel länger dauern als das andere
Das sind die ganzen Körner ja aber ich muss ein volles Upgrade machen
Warum soll ich die Pakete Updaten mit den alten Körnern behalten das wäre ja auch irgendwie beknackt
Das sind 400 MB easy
Von nichts kommt nichts
Die Größe hat aber gar nicht so viel aus zu sagen
Das sind Körner Images und alles die gehen relativ schnell
Aber man kann es nicht wirklich an der Größe ableiten
Zum Beispiel was bei mir unter Anstehung total lang dauert ist ein Visual Studio Code Upgrade
Ich hab bis heute nicht genau verstanden warum
Ich glaub weiter das ganze Programm dreimal zippt, entzippt, tat, enttat und dann noch mal zippt oder sowas
Das ist ein Plusartikel
Ich hab ein Abo seit 20 Jahren aber ich hab mich hier nicht eingeloggt
Dann können wir uns das jetzt nicht angucken
Der Rest ist nicht so langweilig was gibt es sonst noch für
Wir haben vielleicht noch andere News die interessant sind
Benutzst du Visual Studio Code aus dem Auer
Ja ich benutze Visual Studio Code bin weil das normale Visual Studio Code mir zu lange dauert
Guck mal wir sind schon fast fertig
Kann man nichts machen
Oh Huge Procrast Leute
Massive Procrast
Ja das wollte ich auch schon mal ausprobieren
Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren was ist denn da der Unterschied eigentlich
Wir haben Microsoft Geschichten entfernt
Das können wir jetzt mal nebenbei ausprobieren
Weil aktuell haben wir ja Visual Studio Code drauf mit Zeugs
Kann man die Visual Studio Code plugins neu installieren
Was ist der Sinn dahinter in der Uhrleiste immer eine 1 zu schreiben und nicht wieder rauszulöschen
Damit ich die nicht durchdrehe ist da Sinn
Ok dann installieren wir das jetzt mal
So muss ein Paket Manager sein einfach und installiert
Oh die Festplatte geht langsam voll
Wartet mal
Bäm bäm bäm wieder Azitoni
Der Azitoni hat das große Pech gehabt der war zu früh
Der war zu früh guckt euch teilweise Content heute auf YouTube an
Der Azitoni 10 Jahre später
Der hätte heute 1,5 Millionen Abos
True, True, Stimmt's?
True 0W
Ich sag's euch 10 Jahre später hätte der über 1 Millionen Abos heute
Und würde jeden Tag auf der Couch liegen
Und irgendwelche Bäm bäm bäm Videos raushauen
False
So sieht's aus mit ICQ
Ja das mit der 1 kommt tatsächlich daher
Dass ich früher nicht den Leuten irgendwelche falsche Nachrichten schicken wollte
Deswegen aus meinem Clipboard die die Sachen die sie vielleicht hätten aufgeben können raus probiert habe
Oh wir sind schon rüber Installation
Oh VS Kodium Bin und Code are in Conflict
Yes
Ok Code
Ah der behält ok der behält die Plugins
Der behält die Plugins von des gerade
Achso das war mein
Ja brauchen wir nicht
Wir machen hier eh kaum Microcontroller gedönst
Trauen wir nicht
Machen wir dann wenns soweit ist
Ok
Ich verbinde mich jetzt mal hier auf die Kiste
Und ich will mich nicht einfach nur verbinden per Text
Glaub mir es gibt genug Leute das verbinden
So jetzt bin ich hier remote remote auf dieser Kiste drauf
So das kennt man ja
Eines der praktischsten Sachen die es per SSH gibt ist Minus Y oder Minus X
Minus Y ist das neuere Minus X
Und wenn man das macht ich hoffe dass ich bei mir lokal alles
Oh fuck ich hab's nicht installiert
Ok
Da kann ich es euch so gar nicht zeigen
Da kann ich es euch nicht zeigen ich brauch irgendeine Kiste wo ich das mal zeigen kann
Mein Server kann ich euch zeigen
Mal kurz gucken was das Ding
Oder die kurz die IP raussuchen
Ich weiß aber mein Passwort nicht mehr
Was hab ich denn da hier
Max
Ah yes
Max ajaja
Zum Beispiel wenn man da einen Firefox oder
Ich installier mal was was ich euch zeigen kann sonst ist es halt doof
Erstmal 3 Milliarden Sachen installiert um was zeigen zu können
So also wenn man sich jetzt per SSH auf einen Remote Server verbindet
In dem Fall verbinde ich mich auf den hier
Und man braucht mal das kommt öfters mal vor man braucht mal ein
Ein grafisches Programm dann geht das
Diese Uhr läuft jetzt nicht bei mir lokal sondern auf dem Server
Natürlich ist es mit der Uhr ziemlich sinnlos
Aber wenn man das zum Beispiel mit einem Browser mit einem Firefox oder einem Chrome macht
Kann das sehr praktisch sein zum Beispiel wenn man irgendwo sich drauf getunnelt hat per SSH
Und man muss dann auf irgendein Web Interface
Das heißt das ist dort lokal im Netz wo man mit SSH ist
Kommt man da ohne Probleme hin das Problem ist nur
Man kommt halt mit seinem lokalen Browser nicht hin
Deswegen gibt es die Möglichkeit mit SSH-X bzw.
Minus Y grafische Programme weiterzuleiten
Ich installiere mir mal einen Firefox
Wir probieren es jetzt ich zeige euch jetzt mal dass es funktioniert
Zwar jede Menge Crap den ich jetzt drauf installiere und erstmal wieder wegschmeißen muss
Aber ok kann ich immer noch machen
Das mit Port weiterzuleiten machen wir gleich
So jetzt installieren wir mal einen Firefox und jede Menge Crap noch auf meiner Kiste hier nebendran
Und wenn ich jetzt Firefox starte dann man merkt es ist langsam
Wohlgemerkt also ihr seht es ist jetzt nicht sonderlich schnell
Dieser Firefox hier der läuft nicht bei mir lokal, man sieht ja auch wie lahm der ist
Der läuft nicht lokal auf meiner VM oder hier auf meinem Desktop
Sondern der läuft jetzt auf dem Server
Das heißt wenn ich jetzt von hier irgendwo drauf zugreifen will
Ich muss mal überlegen auf was
Zum Beispiel eine Sache wo ich nur
Machen wir das jetzt am besten
Zum Beispiel die Sache die ich habe nur im WLAN das Management für meinen Unify Access Point
Und wenn ich da hin will mache ich das da und das geht von diesem Browser aus weil der im richtigen Netz ist
Oder auch nicht kommt da gar nicht hin stimmt
Was auch immer was kann ich euch denn zeigen
Ich kann Google aufmachen über den Remote
Das wichtige was ich dabei sagen will ist eigentlich nur ihr könnt grafische Programme über SSH weiterleiten
Ohne dass ihr das Programm lokal braucht bzw. ohne dass ihr da überhaupt lokal hinkommt
Mit dem Browser auf Daten auf dem Server zugreifen ja das geht auch
Funktioniert sieht man nämlich hier dran
Wie plantet man das Menü überhaupt ein
Öffnen
Guckt
Das ist das ist das ist auf dem
Das ist jetzt auf dem Server drauf hier das File System
Das ist auf das ist auf dem Server drauf nicht bei mir lokal
Das ist halt sehr praktisch
So jetzt muss ich die ganzen Crap erstmal wieder löschen
Wie ging das nochmal
Remove purge purge
Wie konnte man ab remove all dependencies wie konnte man den ganzen Crap wieder löschen
Der Pudge löscht die Datei ich brauche hier auch die Abhängigkeit auto remove oder
Und
Der Raspberry Pi erkennt das als serielle Schnittstelle
Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit da selbst zu bauen mit dann halt wirklich seriell
Und das dann nicht mit dem Raspberry sondern mit einem Microcontroller zu machen
Aber ich habe keinen Bock den Gramm selbst zu lösen und zu basteln
Weil ich es halt mit dem Raspberry Pi
Mit was kann man dann auslesen und steuern
So gut so gut wie alles eigentlich also du kannst Temperatur auslesen
Du kannst sogar die Neigung auslesen wie das Ding steht
Aber so viel habe ich noch nicht ausgelesen
Ich habe bisher nur Temperatur ausgelesen und ob Fehler ob es Fehler hat oder nicht
Das ist ja auch eines der Sachen die ich heute machen wollte
Mal gucken was man noch alles noch alles so auslesen kann
Ändern kannst du theoretisch auch das habe ich mich aber bis jetzt noch nicht getraut
Das geht
Also man kann neben auslesen auch ändern
Aber das habe ich mich noch nicht getraut
Hat der Pi eigentlich Bluetooth oder Infrarot?
Bluetooth
WLAN, Bluetooth
Die Dinger baust du?
Ahja nice
Huge
Sag mal wenn du dich damit auskennst
Verwenden die intern wirklich so eine wilde Mischung aus
Verwenden die intern wirklich so eine wilde Mischung aus Deutsch und Englisch wie das
Ich zeige dir mal ein Beispiel
Zum Beispiel verwenden die intern auch so komische Dinge wie
Getch Störungen und sowas
Oder Getch Temp
Getch Temp Aged und Getch Temp WW soll
Und Getch Temp WW ist
Oder haben sich das die Leute hier von dieser komischen Software ausgedacht
Kann eigentlich nicht sein weil da schickt es ja glaube ich über seriell rüber
Verwenden die wirklich so eine wilde Mischung aus Englisch und Deutsch
So eine Sache wollte ich ja mit SSH noch zeigen
Kann man die Peppers ein bisschen leiser machen
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel nur von diesem Server an was drankomme dann kann ich sagen
Manchmal ist das nicht sauber beschrieben
So ich kann zum Beispiel ein Port weiterleiten ich kann sagen
Ich nehme lokal bei mir ein Port
Jetzt haben wir Port 1234
Mein lokalen Port 1234
Und den leiten wir weiter ich hatte es doch eben auf
Und den leiten wir weiter
Ich brauche kurz einen Lookup
So und den lokalen Port leiten wir weiter auf diese IP
Und diesen Port
So und wenn ich jetzt den Tunnel aufbaue
Dann kann ich auf localhost 1234 gehen
Und ich komme auf meinem Unifier Interface raus
Und ihr seht Port und Host sind komplett anders
Das liegt daran, weil ich mich jetzt über SSH drüber getunnelt habe
Und das ist natürlich sehr praktisch dafür
Wenn ich auf Sachen zugreifen will
Wo ich nicht darauf zugreifen darf aber ein anderer Server
Was auch noch sehr praktisch ist bei der SSH Geschichte
Man kann auch remote einen Port aufmachen
Und da wird es wirklich spannend
Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel irgendeinen Server im Internet habe
Und möchte da irgendwas weiter leiten zu mir lokal
Das zeige ich euch jetzt nicht
Aber so angemerkt wie das funktioniert
Da gibt es die Kombination aus SSH minus R und minus G
Und das macht folgendes wenn ich dort auch wieder angebe
Dann sorgt das dafür, dass ich jetzt auf diesem Server einen Port aufmache
Der offen ist für alle anderen
Das heißt ich kann quasi einen Port im Internet aufmachen
Über den ich dann irgendwelche Leute von außen zu mir reintunneln kann
Über SSH
Also SSH ist insgesamt eines der praktischsten Tools überhaupt
Was? Hä was Knäherbär schon?
Komisch das es leichter ist ein Amoklauf Video unseres zu finden als das Video vom Hanauer Laufer
Was?
Naja so Sachen werden halt mittlerweile direkt gelöscht auf YouTube
Das hat auch auf YouTube finde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt so viel zu suchen
Es gibt so viele Seiten die irgendwelche Videos veröffentlichen
Aus Kriegsgebieten und Leaks und sonst was
Da wird man das garantiert auch uncensiert finden
Auf YouTube will ich solchen Sachen eigentlich gar nicht aus Versehen über den Weg laufen
Doki ich würde es dir jetzt ja zeigen allerdings der Chat war der Meinung
Ich soll doch erstmal ein Update von meinem Pile Zero machen und das dauert halt ewig
Aber ich kann euch nur empfehlen wenn ihr ein bisschen was im Bereich Server Administration zu tun habt
Selbst wenn ihr nur Anwendungsentwickler, Programmierer seid, hobbymäßig daheim was macht
Guckt euch bisschen genauer SSH an was man machen kann
Weil SSH ist oftmals die Lösung für viele Probleme
Von denen man erstmal gar nicht denkt dass SSH die Lösung dafür sein könnte
XSolution
Wie gesagt SSH FS auch super
Die ganze SSH Kombination also man kann da sehr viel machen
Q-Chat Ratschläge so sieht es aus
Aber
Oh wir haben es gleich 88% Leute
Und dann und pass auf danach mache ich ein Reboot der sauber startet nicht mehr und dann mache ich ein Stream aus
Dann ist der Chat dran Schuld
Dann will ich sehen was deine Heizung so sagt
Ja bin ich auch mal gespannt drauf was meine Heizung so sagt
Oh ja wenn du dich damit auskennst ist interessant
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf
Würdest du dir das PS5 oder das neue Xbox Revealevent im Stream anschauen?
Ja wann ist das?
Aha März
Wann weiß man da schon genau was?
Ja auf jeden Fall das gucken wir uns also wenn das jetzt nicht gerade nachts ist oder so gucken wir uns das jetzt auf jeden Fall an
Oh ist das lahm
Brauchen wir zur Entspannung ein bisschen hier
Ein bisschen Passive Effects
Also der Zero ist halt wirklich lahm wie Sau
Das Update war vor einer Stunde
Mal eher eineinhalb Stunden
Eine neue Installation auf Raspberry Zero ist schneller
Wer ist Schuld an dem Update?
Der Chat
Bist du Programmierer von Beruf?
Ich mache alles ein bisschen also was ich aktuell mache ich habe sogar ein Video dazu
Was ich aktuell so mache habe ich hier mal zusammengefasst 14 Minuten Video auf YouTube
Ich mache alles ein bisschen
Ich habe mal ursprünglich Fachinformatiker System Integration gelernt aber das ist schon 15 Jahre schon ewig her
Es wurden schon mehr als vier Zeichen kopiert Leute
Ich habe locker schon 15 kopiert
Also ich habe mal irgendwann Fachinformatiker System Integration gelernt vor 15 Jahren oder so
Mittlerweile programmiere ich fast mehr als dass ich Server administriere
Aber es ist auch etwas was mich interessiert das hatte jeder so seine Vorlieben bei der ganzen Sache
88% Leute es geht weiter
Ich muss jetzt die 88 weg machen bevor die Verschwörungstheoretiker wieder kommen
Ich habe mir Programmieren beigebracht Smart Home zu bauen
Smart Home ist eh so eine Geschichte die man nicht fertigen Software und fertige Hardware von irgendwelchen Herstellern überlässt
Die erstens überhaupt nicht zu dem passt was man braucht
Und wo man nicht weiß was es intern macht Smart Home ist eine Sache die muss man zum größten Teil selber machen
Dass es ordentlich funktioniert
Ich habe bei mir ja auch jede Menge Zeug am Start
Wir haben ja hier im Stream auch schon viel gemacht
Auch alles offline ohne Cloud
Oh 89 Leute
Pock
Das ist toll wenn der Sound leckt oder
Wenn der Sound leckt kann ich nämlich kann ich nämlich den Sound starten und das Bild und das Bild ändern
Geht aufwärts Leute die Stonks reisen
Home Assistant ist irgendwie komisch
Home Assistant ist Pock
Welches an der Smart Home Projekt helfen im Alltag am meisten
Kommt auf die Jahreszeit an
Also im Sommer finde ich das mit der Klimaanlage ganz praktisch dass er das anhand meiner Richtung im Zug schon vorausschauend anschalten kann
Ist ja praktisch
Am coolsten ist das
Das benutze ich aber halt nicht weil ich kein Fernsehen gucke
Aber am coolsten finde ich nach wie vor obwohl das eigentlich der eines der ersten Sachen war die ich gebaut habe
Die Sache mit dass der Film auf dem Fernsehen automatisch Pause macht wenn das Telefon klingelt
Das finde ich sehr nice
Was ich auch ganz praktisch finde ist die RGB Lampe die mir die Zugverspätung anzeigt schon wenn ich aufstehe
Also sprich wenn ich aufstehe und man weiß schon der Zug hat Verspätung da ist die rot oder das ist dann gelb je nachdem
Ist das nice geht aber nicht mit Kabel Fernsehen klar
Guck fast nur Kabel Fernsehen
Kabel Fernsehen oder aufgenommen das ist überhaupt kein Problem
Im Wohnzimmer steht
Im Wohnzimmer steht ein
So ein Ding
So ein Ding steht da
Mit einer Zweiteilarbeit Platte drin
Und dort ist am USB ein Dual Tuner
Ein Dual Tuner für DVBC dran
Ich hab diese komische Kappe da nicht hier
Auf dem Kopf weil das Ding hat unten so ne Passivkühlrippen
Und das Ding macht die Aufnahmen
Und da hab ich eingestellt dass das quasi immer wenn man Fernsehen guckt auch automatisch gleich Timeshift macht
Also du kannst immer während Fernsehen läuft kannst du immer Pause machen
Das einzige wo es nicht geht und mit nicht geht meine ich nicht jetzt nicht nur die Pause nicht geht sondern
Was überhaupt gar nicht
Anschaubar ist was was nicht läuft ist private Sender in HD
Weil private Sender in HD
Irgendwie im Jahr 2005 hängen geblieben sind
Und ihr als einzige ihre ihre HD Programme
Noch mit nur Smartcard only ausstrahlen
Und das ist halt ziemlich keckwe
Es ist übrigens auch egal wie man das macht über Satellit ist es das gleiche
Alles andere kein Problem
Und auch private SD kein Problem
Smartcard und Geld
Und nur auf oh wir sind fertig Leute krasser Shit
Und natürlich auch nur das geht mit Smartcard geht ja auch nur mit offizieller Unity Media Hardware was ja gerade der größte Witz ist
Und das wollte ich mir gar nicht geben
Ich habe mich schon überlegt ob ich mal Satu Satu verwende
Für für privat weil da ist das anders
Aber ganz eigentlich nachdem ich kein Fernsehen kucke drauf geschissen
Okay wir haben geupgraded war es das jetzt
Haben wir es jetzt geschafft Dist Upgrade haben wir gemacht alles gut
Blablabla Autoremoved das machen wir noch
Das machen wir noch das ganze
Das ganze Zeug aufräumen dann danach wird Rebootet Leute
Okay jetzt sehen wir gleich ob es funktioniert hat
Das machen wir garantiert nicht
Zeig mal gelegentlich ne kann ich nicht
Ich habe einen zweiten Homosystem installiert für den Stream
Aber einen eigentlichen Homosystem kann ich nicht zeigen da sind zu viel private
Zeug drin
Yes okay das geht jetzt schnell da muss den Kram einfach nur löschen
Das dauert jetzt 1-2 Minuten
Und dann ist Reboot und dann ist RIP
Aber
Kann man nichts machen wenn das kaputt ist
Ich wollte mal ein Video drüber machen
Da kann ich nämlich im Vorfeld einfach dann ein neues Dashboard anlegen
Wo man nur sieht was man sehen darf
So Chat jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit
Gleich kommt der Reboot und gucken ob es funktioniert
So was meint ihr klappt es oder klappt es nicht?
MonkaS Smoke oder Hyper S?
Wird schon
Okay Leute 3-2-1 Bam
Ah
Haha
Warum musste ich denn das vorher nicht machen?
Warum musste ich denn das?
Ich habe nämlich ich habe das überall installiert dass man nicht aus Versehen Rebooten kann
Warum musste ich denn das vorher nicht machen?
Das habe ich auf allen meinen Servern installiert dass ich nicht aus Versehen Reboote
Okay 3-2-1 Bam
Okay er ist weg
23-23-50 ist er weg
Schauen wir mal ob er wieder hoch kommt
Das dauert mir schon ein bisschen lang
Höhe
Das war's für heute.
Bei der Schule caubert.
Bei der Learning
Bei der Teaching
Bei der Teacher
Part of the Class has picked
Part of the Class protect
Das war's für heute.
8 mal pro Stunde neu oder wie?
Warum macht er denn so Sachen?
Yep, schlecht.
Und jetzt?
Vor Verschleiß.
Das heißt die Typen, die das eingebaut haben, die sucken.
Die haben keine Ahnung, was sie eingestellt haben.
Das macht eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Naja, aber es kommt da raus und sieht jetzt auch nicht aus, als würde er irgendeinen Mist auslesen.
Wie würde das denn normalerweise aussehen?
Wie würde das normal aussehen?
Ich meine, dass er nicht...
Die Kiste gibt Vollgas und bremst ab.
Ich meine, dass er nicht eine ganze Stunde am Stück läuft, kann ich verstehen.
Ist ja irgendwie logisch, wenn er nicht die ganze Stunde...
Wie ist denn so ein gutes Verhältnis denn?
Quasi halb so viele Stunden wie Neustarts oder Drittelstunden wie Neustarts oder eins zu eins?
Oder was ist da so normal?
Ich habe eine Idee, wir machen jetzt Big Brain Kommando.
Passt mal auf, was wir jetzt machen.
Wir machen jetzt eine Schleife.
Und zwar, wir schleifen über alle Kommandos und lassen uns...
Jedes Kommando fragen wir einmal ab und geben es aus.
Es gab noch Get-Stand-By-Zeit.
Dann probieren wir das nochmal aus.
Get-Stand-By.
Wer hat den gerade benannt, ey?
Was?
Ah, Zeit-Stand-By.
Stand-By.
Wenn man ca. 2 Stunden Laufzeit mit einem Start hat.
Also 2 zu 1, okay.
Das heißt, es ist komplett falsch rum bei mir, ne?
So was du jetzt sagst ist, man sollte eigentlich mehr Stunden Laufzeit haben als Starts.
Und nicht wie bei mir, quasi viel mehr Starts als Laufzeit.
Get-Betriebszeit-Stand-By.
Oh, das geht nicht.
Tipp.
Wäre top, ja.
Ne, ich geh da nicht ins Forum.
Ich sag das einfach mal dem Typ, der sich um die Sachen kümmert.
Ich sag das dem Heizungsmensch, der soll sich das angucken.
Ich mach da nix, ich stell da auch nix.
Verbrauchst zu viel, aha.
Naja, ich kann den Kram ja mal auslesen.
Und einfach dem, ich weiß, was für ein Laden ist das überhaupt.
Das ist nicht der Elektriker, ich überleb grad, welcher Laden das war, der das gemacht hat.
Aber ich könnt es denen ja einfach mal zeigen, ne?
Ähm.
Hast du denn hohe Heizkosten?
Ja gut, ich hab wenig Vergleich, ja.
Ich weiß aber auch grad aus dem Kopf echt nicht, wie viel es ist.
Also das ist keine, das ist ne Gasheizung, keine Ölheizung, ne?
Okay, wir machen jetzt hier noch, ich wollte mal sagen, Big Brain Command.
Also hier, Cut.
Erzähl mir ein paar Ecken, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht, keine Ahnung.
Boah, du fragst jetzt Sachen, ich kann keine Ahnung aus dem Kopf.
Weiß ich beim besten Willen nicht.
Müsste ich nachgucken.
Dann müsste ich echt nachgucken, ich weiß es nicht.
Äh, zwei Personen.
Mit warmem Wasser, ja?
Ja, ja, mit warmem Wasser.
Aber, boah, ich hab echt aus dem Kopf keine Ahnung.
So, also jetzt, wir machen jetzt mal ne Schleife.
Wir lesen jetzt Heizkörper.
Wie viele?
Meinst du, wie viele Heizkörper?
Ja, Heizkörper.
So, so, so, Heizkörper mit diesen normalen Drehventildingern da.
Also, wie auch immer das.
Nicht Ventil.
So, so, hier, diese Drehdinger.
Ganz normale Heizkörper, ja?
So, also, vor, vor, i, in, da, du, echo, i, dann.
So, und jetzt, wir fragen jetzt einfach mal alles ab.
Wir fragen jetzt einfach mal alles ab, was es gibt.
Und schauen mal, was da so rauskommt.
Ja.
Das dauert jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen kurz, aber wir sehen, was passiert.
Okay.
Äh, Moment, wir machen nach, nach jeder, nach jeder Ausgabe, machen wir noch nen Echo.
Äh, hier.
Das, das wir sehen, das vorbei ist.
Drehventildinger.
Wie viel verbrauchst du?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab echt keinen Plastenschimmer.
Aber ich kann nachgucken und dir das erzählen, ja?
Das ist nicht diesen Stream, aber, ähm, also, falls du irgendwann demnächst nochmal reingucken
solltest, ich guck mal nach, da kann ich dir das sagen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Guck mal hier, die Neigung.
Neigung M2, 1,4.
Getpumpedrehzahlintern.
Also, die Benamungen sind wirklich Next Level Big Brain, oder?
Fisher M2.
Okay, aktuell haben wir, das ist Außentemperatur, Gettemp A, 10 Grad.
10 Grad wird Außentemperatur sein, denk ich mal.
Richtig Pfeifer.
Temp wie ist, Gettemp wie soll, Gettemp STP.
Was zum Geier ist STP 2?
Erstmal die Heizung mit Grafana tracken, das machen wir noch.
Wir basteln uns einen eigenen Gett Öldurchsatz.
Das ist Öl?
Das ist keine Ölheizung.
Sollte ich mir jetzt Gedanken machen, wenn ich Öldurchsatz hab, ohne eine Ölheizung zu haben?
Raumtemp.
Gett STS soll 2.
Also, man muss sagen, die Benamungen der Variablen, die ist schon wirklich Next Level.
Okay, ah, guck mal, wir sehen den Timer.
5.30 Uhr geht's an und um 22 Uhr geht's aus.
Get Timer M1 Freitag.
Und Dienstag geht's erst um 6 Uhr an.
Nee.
Ach, kann das sein, dass das 1. Stock und 2. Stock ist?
Stimmt denn die Raumtemperatur?
Was hab ich jetzt nicht gesehen?
Die Raumtemperatur bei mir ist grad irgendwie 24 Grad oder so.
Ich hab volle Pulle an, auf Stufe.
Nein, nicht volle Pulle, auf dreieinhalb hab ich stehen.
Den Egal-GIF?
Okay, kann ich auf Discord posten.
Gett Betriebsart.
Heizen und warm Wasser, könnte das sein?
Heizen und warm Wasser?
Und Betriebsart 2 ist Heizen, warm Wasser und File Server.
Oder was auch immer FS ist.
Deswegen hat er eben Samba geupdatet.
Get Timer Zirkus?
Ist das echt so?
Get Timer Zirkus.
Ja.
Keine Fehler, keine Fehler.
Ah, yes, keine Fehler.
System Time, 17.06 Uhr, stimmt, korrekt.
Get K5.
Was man da alles auslesen kann.
Ich hab legit keinen flassen Schimmer, was uns das alles sagt.
Aber wichtig für mich ist nur, dass ich sehe, falls die nen Fehler hat.
Und ähm, die Temperatur oder so.
Sagst du auch, man kann mehr oder weniger alles auslesen, ja.
Das ist huge.
Get Inventory, ist das irgendwie die Seriennummer?
Kann das sein, dass das die Seriennummer ist?
Get Konfi Wirkung auf Bombe.
Get K3 Konfi Frostgrenzen M1 Gibi.
Also die variablen Benamungen von Wiesmann ist schon wirklich
Absolute Big Brain, ey. Kann man nix anderes sagen.
So, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, das können wir alles auslesen.
Aber, aber das ist schon, das ist schon eine tolle Benamung, oder?
Get Konfi Frostgrenze M1 GWG.
Das war's. Das haben wir alles auslesen.
Ich hab gefiltert nach Get.
Also sprich, wir können mal gucken, was man auch einstellen könnte.
Aber das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Also man könnte wahrscheinlich den meisten Kram hier auch einstellen.
Set, Set Neigung.
SetWumWumWumWum nachLauf.
Was ohne Code?
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie man Sachen einstellt.
Ich trau mich nicht.
Ich hab bisher, ich bin immer zum einer aus- schalten wenn ich das, wenn
man was war, oder was man machen muss, bitte über die Keller gegangen.
Ich hab mich noch nicht, ich hab mich noch nicht getraut,
hier irgendwas zu setzen über die Software.
Ich habe bisher nur ausgelesen, ich habe auch nicht vor was zu setzen, weil im Zweifelsfall verstelle ich irgendwas.
Warmwasserumwälzpumpensteuerung. Ah, yes.
Exzellent. Hier lernt man noch was heute.
Rein theoretisch kannst du dir auch via Nagios ein paar Checks einrichten, wenn irgendwas critical rutscht.
Ja, das ist der Ziel des Ganzen. Also ich möchte zwei Sachen. Ich will einmal, dass es wieder Daten in meinen Home Assistant, in meine Heimautomatisierung schickt.
Sowas wie Temperatur und ob es einen Fehler hat.
Allerdings die Sache mit ob es einen Fehler hat, das kommt bei mir auch ins Monitoring rein, was ich sehe.
Aber in der Heimautomatisierung ist es natürlich auch nicht verkehrt, wenn man das sieht.
Ich habe ja im Flur und am Badeingang jeweils ein Dashboard Tablet im Flur hängen.
Und sprich, wenn ich morgens da vorbeilaufe, dann geht das automatisch an.
Das ist übrigens richtig big brain gemacht. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich dir schon mal gezeigt habe, wie das funktioniert.
Das sind Amazon Tablets. Am Bad ist noch ein altes, älteres Android Tablet. Also nichts von Amazon.
Und das habe ich so eingestellt, dass das Wall Panel heißt das.
Ja, das da. Das ist wirklich sehr praktisch. Da habe ich meine Heimautomatisierung drin auf.
Und der hat das übrigens auch hier in den Home Assistant.
Und das coole ist, das hat jede Menge Sonderfunktionen für genau solche Sachen, dass man das Tablet als Dashboard eingesetzt werden kann.
Zum Beispiel können sich die Tablets über Motion Detection und Face Detection vom Bildschirm einschalten und das Dashboard zeigen.
Und das ist halt echt praktisch. Ich habe das so eingestellt, dass wenn man dran vorbeiläuft, wenn man nach 5 Uhr dran vorbeiläuft,
dann geht das Display an durch Motion Detection und man sieht direkt, was in der Heimautomatisierung ist.
Man könnte das noch ein bisschen weiter spinnen. Man könnte beispielsweise es auch per Face Detection machen.
Also sprich, dass nicht einfach nur wenn einer durch den Flur rennt, das Dashboard angeht, sondern wenn jemand davor steht.
Das ist wirklich coole Software und das Beste ist, die ist komplett kostenlos.
Wenn morgens so scheiße aussieht, dass deine Heizung dich nicht erkennt. Das ist mir ziemlich...
Das juckt mich nicht, aber Hauptsache ich erkenne im Dashboard was.
Genau und ich habe eben im Flur zwei Fire HD 10 hängen neben dem Telefon dagegen für die Tür-Gegensprechanlage.
Weil, das ist nämlich Absicht gewesen, wenn die Haustür klingelt, dann kann der hier automatisch auf den Dashboards auf die Kamera im Hof schalten.
Und dann sieht man meistens, was da Sache ist. Ich habe keine Kamera auf der Straße, ich habe euch ja mal erzählt, ich wollte das machen,
aber erstens ist das nicht erlaubt und zweitens habe ich da nichts Gescheites gefunden dafür, wie ich das ordentlich verstecken kann und trotzdem was filmen kann.
Ich habe aber eine Kamera im Hof, die kennt ihr ja, habe ich euch schon gezeigt.
Und man erkennt da nicht wirklich was durch, zumal das Tor ja auch so eine Folie davor hat, so ein Plastik.
Aber man erkennt zum Beispiel, ob da ein DHL-Auto, ein Hermes-Auto steht oder was da so ungefähr davor steht vom Tor.
Musst du so steuern, dass bei Fehlern das Board blinkt?
Ja, könnte man theoretisch machen. Aber wenn die Heizung einen Fehler hat, merke ich das morgens relativ schnell, weil die Heizung nicht angeht.
Dann kann ich draufgucken.
Ablesen muss da eh keiner, abgelesen wird unten im Keller am Anschluss, da ist egal was du für Werte schickst, das kannst du da glaube ich auch so gar nicht richtig erkennen.
Alu, Alu ist so ein Cloud-Ding. Ich habe bisher nichts gescheites gefunden, ich habe ein paar ganz gute Sachen, was aber daran scheitert für Stromversorgung draußen an der Wand.
Hast du auch am Eingang ein Schild mit der DS? Natürlich. Was denkst du dann? Denkst du etwa, dass mir das wäre?
Ja, Kabel ist kein Problem. Ich muss das nur da vorne hinkriegen und dann an der Stelle wo ich auch irgendwie was hinstelle.
Also ich hab's mir ja schon überlegt, ob ich das nicht dort einbaue, wo meine Tür ging. Hab ich euch das nicht schon gezeigt sogar?
Jetzt hab ich euch doch sogar schon mal gezeigt, wie das da aussieht.
Das hab ich euch doch schon mal gezeigt, wie das vorne bei meiner Tür Gegensprechanlage aussieht.
Hab ich das nicht sogar auf Twitter gepostet, wo ich den Kram eingebaut hab?
Wie, ich kann nicht auf Media-Ansicht schalten? Alter Twitter, geh mal nicht auf den Sack.
Warum gängelt ihr mich so sehr mit meinem eigenen Account, Alter?
Ok, suchen wir mal.
Tür? Tür?
Oh, das ist meine ganz alte Katz. Das ist originale Katz-FPS, die ich da gerade gefunden hab.
Originale Katz-FPS, das heißt, das Foto ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Ich bin neu hier und hab eine Frage, was für ein Betriebssystem benutzt ihr?
Also hier ist gerade Windows und für die ganzen Programmiergeschichten und Raspberry Geschichten, das ist Banjaro Linux.
Hast du auch einen Pi bei der Katze am Kram? Nein, Quatsch.
Ich hab auch gar keinen Raspberry Pi auf dem Friedhof, das ist ein ESP32.
Na was könnte man da suchen?
Gegen-Sprech-Anlage, sowas hab ich nicht geschrieben, das Wort ist viel zu... Doch! Gegen-Sprech-Anlage, da ist es doch. Ich hab wirklich das Wort Gegen-Sprech-Anlage verwendet, Alter.
So sieht das aus. Also, ich hab vorne den Teil abgemacht von der Gegen-Sprech-Anlage und hab einen Exist-Point dahinter gestöpselt.
Big Brain Move, ja. Also das hängt nur hier, das ist halt alles dahinter normalerweise.
Also hier vorne ist die Gegen-Sprech-Anlage dran, das sieht man jetzt hier nicht, weil das ist halt nicht im Bild drin.
Und ich hatte noch zwei Adern frei, noch zwei Adern hatte ich aus dem Keller frei, die haben so ganz normales Verlegekabel genommen, da sind glaube ich sechs Adernpaare drin.
Und vier Adernpaare braucht die hier, die Gegen-Sprech-Anlage. Und zwei Adernpaare waren noch frei.
Das heißt, was hab ich gemacht? Ich hab innen drinnen einen 48 Volt Netzteil genommen, an die zwei Adernpaare gestöpselt und hab dann draußen hinter die Abdeckung einen PoE-Injector genommen.
Da kommt quasi hier aus der Wand, kommt das Kabel, was am 48 Volt Netzteil hängt, raus, geht in den PoE-Injector rein und der PoE-Injector geht in den Exist-Point und betreibt den Exist-Point.
So und der Exist-Point kann dann wiederum theoretisch ein weiteres Gerät auch noch über PoE versorgen, falls man das bräuchte.
Das ist mein Next Level. Allerdings muss ich dazu sagen, das Zeug ist eingebaut und funktioniert, aber ich verwende es gerade aktuell nicht.
Äh, gute Frage. Was ist... Äh, ja... So, ähm... Darf ich dir gleich...
Was ist der Unterschied, ob das einzelne... Äh... Achso, das ist die Frage, ob das so Litzen sind oder ob das durchgängig ist.
Äh... Die sind durchgängig. So was ist das, glaub ich. So was hier ist das, glaub ich.
Da waren nämlich keine... Da waren keine Fasern irgendwie drinne. Also so Dinger waren das nicht, das waren durchgängige.
Also es waren keine, keine kleinen Kabel in Kabel. Achso, boah, ich hab keine Ahnung. Äh, frag mich nicht.
Aber ich mein, das sind... Was ist denn das... Was geht da drüber? Das PoE Zeug ist... Ähm... Ist das überhaupt ein PoE?
Es könnte sogar nur ein 12 Watt PoE Injector sein. Nichtsdestotrotz, ich mein, das sind maximal... Was wären das dann? 48 Volt mit irgendwie... Was ist das? 48 Volt, ein Ampere maximal?
Das ist zumindest nichts. Das trau sogar ich, mich anzugreifen.
Ey, bei uns im Keller im Schaltschrank hab ich echt richtig hardcore hier... MonkaS letztens.
Ähm... Als ich da reingeguckt hab, war aufgefallen, dass die Leute, die das installiert haben, die haben quasi die Kabel im Haus durch Rohre gezogen mit Kupfer...
Also die haben quasi so Kupferkabel drumherum gewickelt und haben die dann durchs Rohr geschoben, oben das Kabel dran gebunden und dann das durchgezogen.
Und die haben das nicht richtig abgeschnitten. Als ich da mal letztens reingeguckt hab, hab ich festgestellt, die Kupferkabel hängen noch quasi im Schaltschrank rum.
Hinter der Abdeckung und könnten theoretisch, wenn man nicht aufpasst, jederzeit in irgendeinen Kontakt reinrutschen.
Das ist aber sehr unordentlich, was die da gemacht haben. Gut, ich hab's abgeschnitten dann aber.
Also schön war das, schön war das nicht, die die da gebastelt haben.
Ja, das hab ich gebraucht, weil für die Stromversorgung der Heimautomatisierungs-Dashboards im Flur, da hab ich das Rohr verwendet, wo die Telefone für die Türgegensprechanlage durchgekommen sind.
Also ich mein, wenn da schon ein Rohr liegt, kann sich das Leben auch schwer machen, deswegen hängen die Tablets auch direkt neben den Telefonen im Flur, weil da halt ein Rohr ist.
Jaja, so sieht's aus.
Naja, das ist an der Türgegensprechanlage schon eingebaut worden, das heißt, ich könnte da jederzeit upgraden mit einer Kamera oder irgendwie was anderes dahin bauen.
Hab ich jetzt aber bis jetzt nicht vor, weil es passt ganz gut. Ich schalte einfach die Tablets um auf die Kamera im Hof und man sieht genug.
Gut, also jetzt noch großartige Progress anfangen ist, schaff ich gehirnmäßig nicht mehr nach drei Stunden Stream. Ursprüngliche Idee war ja, was ich hatte ist, ich wollte mir jetzt was basteln, irgendein.NET Programm, was auf diesen V-Control zugreift.
Wir probieren mal ganz kurz aus. Leute, wollen wir nochmal ausprobieren, ob das zumindest theoretisch funktioniert? Also, Telnet 1221681.51102, bam, funktioniert. Achso, das ist ja kein HTTP.
Was hatten wir hier für schöne, schöne Commands, die wir ausprobieren? Get-Störung gab es hier doch irgendwie. Get-Störung, wo ist es, Leute? Egal, Get-Brenner-Status, kann ich auch abrufen.
Wupp, wupp, der Kommentator, drei Monate. Pepo-Clap, sehr nice. Und das komplette Gegenteil von...
Danke schön für den Sub. Huge, drei Monate Sub. So, kann man das jetzt einfach hier einfügen? Get-Brenner-Status, null Prozent. So, haben wir vielleicht irgendwas, wo ein bisschen was zurückkommt?
Get, wo nicht gerade null zurückkommt, was machen wir denn? Get-Brenner-Stunden oder so, ne? Stunden. Ne, wie hieß das? Hier, Get-Brenner-Stunden.
Ach, das geht nur eins gleichzeitig. Get-Brenner-Stunden-1, okay. Get-Brenner-Stunden-1. Probieren wir mal aus, ob wir da... das testen wir jetzt nochmal schnell, ob wir aus Konsolenprogrammen...
Ob wir aus dem Konsolenprogramm, nennen wir es mal irgendwie, be-client, was abgefragt bekommen vom Raspberry Pi. Das probiere ich jetzt nochmal schnell aus.
Aber schön mache ich es nicht, sage ich euch gleich. Ich teste jetzt einfach nur, ob der Kram funktioniert. Und wenn es funktioniert, machen wir das dann vielleicht morgen Abend oder morgen Mittag oder so weiter.
Einfach nur gucken, ob das klappt. Ups. Port. Äh, wat? Was sagt hier? Ah, ich hab mich verschrieben.
Okay, connect. So, wir wollen jetzt zu 1.2.1.2.1.1 auf Port 3002. Ähm, dann lassen wir uns mal anzeigen, ob das Ganze connected ist.
Und dann gucken wir, ob das Ding antwortet. Connected. Bam. True. True. Lulw, Leute. True. Und man sieht es auch hier oben. Connected from, das bin ich.
Das bin ich, das hier gerade connected hat. Any trueers. Wenn schon any moxers. Twitch Memes sind die besten.
Okay, wir sind connected. Also sagen wir stream. Get stream. Äh, stream. Das ist jetzt wirklich ganz quick and dirty einfach mal runtergeschrieben. Stream. Read. Read. Äh, so, wir lesen jetzt einfach ein paar bytes und gucken, was da zurückkommt.
Also buffer gleich new 96. Dann lesen wir in den Buffer und kein Offset und volle Buffer, also alles, was in den Buffer reinpasst, lesen wir.
Und dann gucken wir, was er zurückgibt. Und wenn er was zurückgibt, wissen wir, dass es funktioniert. Oh, IP League. Fuck, Alter. Scheiße. IP League.
Encoding. Tja, was meint ihr Leute? Encode die UTF-8 oder encode die ASCII? Also bei Leuten, die solche variable Namen haben, vermute ich mal eher, die encodieren ASCII, oder?
Get-timer-circo-do. Get-pumpe-status-solar. Das ist bestimmt kein UTF-8. Das ist garantiert noch ASCII. 100 pro.
So. Message. So, und da sollte jetzt zurückkommen V-Control-D, wenn ich das richtig sehe. V-Control-D, Leute. Es funktioniert. Also, wir kriegen Verbindungen hergestellt von unserem Konsolprogramm zum Raspberry Pi und können Zeug abfragen.
So, wie hieß das? Get-Brenner-Stunden wollte ich abfragen. Okay. Also, sagen wir, lassen wir das mal unterstehen, sagen jetzt Stream, Write und dann, ach nee, ha. Man kann ja nicht einfach einen String reinschreiben. Das geht nicht. Das ist zu advanced für.NET.
Was ist das für eine Heizung? Irgendeine Wiesbaden-Heizung. Ach, stimmt. Docky, bist noch da? Können wir jetzt abrufen, was das für eine Heizung ist? Erkennt man das? Hast du irgendwie da die krassen Insider-Infos, wie man erkennen kann, was das für eine Heizung ist?
Get-Heizung. Irgendwie Get. Irgendwo. Get-Info. Irgendwie an der Seriennummer oder so.
Get-Info ist es wahrscheinlich eher nicht. Vielleicht kann man es in der Seriennummer erkennen. Okay, also wir schreiben. Ach, da sind keine Seriennummer, okay.
Wer dann weiß, ist es irgendein 0815-Teil? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Irgendeine Wiesbaden-Bito-Blub-Blah, sonst was.
Die Produktbezeichnung finde ich auch nicht sonderlich einleuchtend. Okay, also was müssen wir da jetzt reinschreiben? Get-Brennerstunden.
Also Stream. Auch sagen. Encoding. Get-Bites. Brennerstunden. Ach nee. Kompliziert.
Output. Das ist jetzt nur wild zusammengehackt, um zu gucken, ob es funktioniert. Offset 0. Size 0.
So, wenn ich jetzt richtig gemacht hab, sollte ich hier als Antwort bekommen. Sollte ich als Antwort bekommen, Get-Brennerstunden.
Also sprich das, was in Brennerstunden da halt zurückkommt. Funktioniert nicht. True, 0W.
Standkessel oder Gastherme? Gar nicht, wo der Unterschied ist. Also es ist Gas, auf jeden Fall. Und es steht auf der Erde.
Nee, die hängt nicht. Nee, nee, die hängt nicht. Schreib's nicht in Mess... Ah! Geht trotzdem nicht.
Ah, ich sollte... Nee, ich mach noch mal eine Newline hinten dranne. Genau. Ah, jetzt, jetzt, funktioniert.
Exzellent. Chat, ihr habt wieder. Wisst ihr? Easy, funktioniert. Kann man den Kram abfragen, übers Netzwerk.
17, 19.700 Stunden. Easy. So ist das mal ganz quick and dirty zusammengewurstet.
Da können wir aber was Schönes draus machen, dass ich das besser in meine Heimautomatisierung kriege. Ich mein, so machen wir das nicht.
Ich wollte jetzt einfach nur gucken, ob man prinzipiell abfragen kann. Und man sieht, funktioniert. Sehr schön.
Sehr gut, gefällt mir. Der Auskennfuchs ist auch mal wieder am Start. Big, Big Brain. Alle sind am Chat.
Guck mal, heute läuft der Stream gut. Bisschen Dropped Frames, aber das ist ja nix.
Guck mal, was sonst noch schön ist.
Oh, bisschen was entspanntes. So, hab ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen?
Jetzt trinken geht es leer, jetzt haben wir es schon.
Der im Hengkessel steht. Ja, dann ist es ein Kessel und steht.
Also es sieht ziemlich genau aus wie das Ding, was wir vorher uns angeguckt haben.
Wiesmann, Vito, was? Was? Vito Denz, irgendwas?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, so sieht das nicht aus. Irgendwas Großes.
Also irgendwas, was in der Mitte.
Vito Krossal, nee, nee, das heißt anders. Das Ding ist sieben Jahre alt.
Aber das heißt anders, das heißt nicht Vito Krossal, das wüsste ich.
Das sieht schon so aus, bloß dass da was unten drunter ist.
So hier so, aber nicht so hoch, aber nicht so hoch.
Wir hatten vorher ein ganz gutes Bild.
Irgendjemand hat was von 200F oder so vorhin gepostet, das sah relativ ähnlich aus.
Also es sieht, so ungefähr sieht das aus, das Ding.
333F, das könnte sein. Ja, das könnte, das könnte gut sein.
Das könnte gut sein, sowas hier.
Aber ich glaube von außen sieht der Kram halt für Noobs wie mich alles gleich aus, ja.
Aber im Prinzip ist auch, ist ja egal, ich kann Sachen auslesen, ja.
Also ich muss gar nicht genau wissen, was es ist.
Ansonsten kann ich einfach drauf gehen gucken oder ins Handbuch gucken.
Hätte sein können, dass man das hier irgendwie auslesen kann, weil das wäre cool, wenn das auslesen funktioniert.
Da ist dann ein Trinkwasserspeicher, nee.
So, Wasserspeicher.
Du kannst sicher die Bezeichnung aussehen. Wahrscheinlich, aber ich hab keine Ahnung wie.
Peace Batman.
Ach so, ja doch, klar hab ich ein Trinkwasser.
Also ich hab, klar ist da ein Wasserspeicher dabei.
Doch, doch, auf jeden Fall ist ein Wasserspeicher dabei.
Weil der heizt das ja auf, wenn ich morgens ans Waschbecken gehe.
Nee, daneben steht nix. Das ist so ein komplettes Ding.
Also daneben, ich seh es ja, das steht ziemlich alleine im Raum.
Das ist einfach so diese weiße Kiste hier.
Da muss aber tatsächlich Wasser irgendwo gespeichert werden, weil es kommt ja warmes Wasser raus.
Also sprich, wenn ich warmes Wasser anmache, da kommt ja direkt warmes Wasser raus.
Dann muss es ja ein Wasserspeicher haben irgendwo.
Brennwert, keine Ahnung, für mich sieht das alles ähnlich aus.
So, ja Leute, ich glaub ich geh jetzt mal so langsam was futtern.
Drei Stunden gestremmsort, kommt hinten Kondens, oh boom.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich werd jetzt einfach mal Folgendes machen.
Wenn ich jetzt gleich runtergeh zum Abendessen, guck ich einfach mal ins Handbuch und dann weiß ich was es ist.
Allerdings, wie gesagt, ich kanns ja eh auslesen.
Und was ich mal mache ist, also Doxy, falls du irgendwann demnächst nochmal da sein solltest,
kannst ja nochmal Bescheid sagen, wenn du mal wieder am Start wärst,
dann sag ich dir, wie groß das Haus ist und was das Ding verbraucht.
Aber allgemein kann man schon sagen, dass das Verhältnis von quasi wie lang der Brenner an ist
und wie oft der Brenner neu startet, viel zu hoch ist, oder?
Also ich mein, das Ding startet ja quasi 6-7 Mal mehr als 6-7 Mal in der Stunde irgendwie.
Also der Wert für Brenner an aus ist ja fast 6-7 Mal höher als die Stunden.
Wie ist eingestellt? Ja, wahrscheinlich.
So, ich lass den Kram jetzt mal laufen, oder? Komm, ne. Wir machen das aus.
Ja. Aus.
Ähm, gibt's irgendjemanden, den ich hosten kann? Zeig ich mal her. Was haben wir denn hier Schönes?
Wen können wir dann mal hosten?
Irgendjemand online, den ich kenn?
Nö.
Dann host ich einfach keinen.
So Leute, schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Morgen früh wieder ganz normaler Stream zum Aufwachen.
Und vielleicht, äh, was der Krieger, den Krieger könnten wir tatsächlich hosten.
Jetzt den 8 Minuten.
Ich hoste mal den Krieger, da hab ich das letzte Mal auch gehostet.
Also Leute, machen wir einen Raid. Raid zum Krieger.
Ähm, wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.
Ähm, bis, ja, bis morgen früh, ne. Macht's gut. CU. Bis denn.